and it is the end it all comes down to this in
chess.com puzzle week it's the puzzle battle world
chess championship and alongside me a guy that i i
want to start calling mr puzzles on chest i don't
know why because i know how much you love puzzles
maurice but i'm i'll just go with grandmaster
maurice ashley for now that'll work makes sense
we are we are here to see some of the best in
the world maurice and i know i don't know how many
people know this about you but you're you're not
only a puzzle aficionado and lover of it but you
make your own puzzles so how excited are you to
see guys like ray robson guys like the the guy
that came out of nowhere from greece demetrius
this guy who has been a roughly 2300 player but
maybe maybe one of the best puzzle solvers on the
planet how excited are you today to see what these
specialists can do well you know back in the day
the king was john none part excellence i mean it's
like that guy could look at any puzzle and solve
it i don't care how abstract how obscure how
incredibly esoteric looking it's like the guy
would just be like boo and just get it now to see
these young guns come up and see tactics just like
that or see unusual themes that you just don't see
every day and suddenly they're able to spot them
in seconds it's actually kind of depressing
on one end because you spend a lot of time
creating a puzzle and these guys are solving it
like no problem this is easy it's extraordinary to
see their abilities it takes pattern recognition
to a whole mind-blowing level and one that i'm i'm
always in awe of because i can't put up scores
no matter how hard i try to compete with these
guys but all right let's run through the details
of what is coming up today we got things to remind
the fans of the format the prizes let's jump
in right now so remember first and foremost we
have free puzzles all day long here on january 8th
so if you haven't been paying close attention to
chess.com's puzzle week it's okay even if you're
not a premium member today's your day to dive in
play puzzle battle all day no limitations and
have a blast with it the format of day five is
exactly what we're about to get into it's the
puzzle battle championship like we said not
only free puzzles for all users but we have an
eight player single elimination bracket these
are really the best of the best right we've got
guys like hicaro and nbl who are those household
super grand master names but then we we've got ray
robson we've got uh demetrius lot of houlos we've
got all these guys lined up and remember one of
the fun things about today maurice is it's winner
take all as we bring up the prizes here eight
thousand dollars for first place everybody else
is going home with nothing you like that i know
you like that it's brutal look they've already won
money to get here yes so this is the championship
of championships this puts the nerves on the line
i mean you know it's winner go home this really is
like the final four you know the sweet 16 all the
the great battles that we love to see it's make
it or break it so this is what's up i love this
yep um the uh the bracket as you said um is uh is
the best players they've already they've gotten a
little bit of something to get here many of these
guys have been playing throughout puzzle week but
but these are the guys that got the direct
invitations to play in the puzzle battle
championship um well we go down the list right
it's it's an interesting an interesting balance
of star names guys like ikaru and maxine bashed
the grav who are faced off in the first round
but you've also got ray robson versus eric hanson
there the one eight seed matchup right you've got
jeffrey zhang versus dania naradiski which
is going to be awesome and then you've got
christopher you this this young incredible
talent maybe a future us champion on the
rise right against the the guy that no one really
wants to lose to and i say that kind of jokingly
because he's not a title player and we know that
we you know professionals work super hard they've
got egos right no one wants to lose to a guy
that's not a professional player but he sent
he sent international after grand master home
last year well look but the reality is that this
is a special skill set when you're a title player
you've got the whole package you've got the open
you've got the end game technique right you know
about game management that's a whole different
thing than solving puzzles you can be a puzzle
specialist that's one of the great things about
chess you can be a specialist in an activity
so i don't think people are gonna feel too
much embarrassment losing to a non-title player
because they know if they have to play this guy
in a regular chess game it'll be spanx city but
puzzles this is clearly what he's interested in
and hey we you got to take him down in this
specialty yep and i i got to be honest i think
if one one sort of surprised kid young young
player who could do it it might be christopher
you this guy has been just an absolute monster not
just in puzzles but over the board recently we see
we've seen him make huge strides this year in 2020
as a chess player and uh and he was a guy i think
if i'm remembering last year correctly that made
it to the semi-finals um so uh we'll see how that
shakes out but okay the big big matchup the one
of the two big names we got to talk about right
hikaru nakamura versus mvl they they start out
by rating in the first round right so that wasn't
engineered by us we love it when we get marquee
match-ups we're not going to lie here as chess
commentators and entertainers uh but uh but we
got lucky with this one because in the first round
we've got star power and only one of these guys
will be moving on to the semis i have a hard time
picking this one we know hikaru is going to be
streaming we see what he's capable of we've seen
it all chess.com puzzle week but nbl's getting
ready for uh todd of steel there in viking z
we know he arrived if you follow him on social
media this is a literal coin flip to me maurice
you know i i'm sorry naca is always going to be
the favorite in my book in almost any activity he
does and magnus carlsen is not in it okay if it's
classical chess he hasn't been really focused on
that as much and so his level has somewhat dropped
off but if it's about speed and it's online
i don't care who you've got if you take magnus out
of it naca is my guy so you say coin flip uh i say
knock a flip okay well let's see what these guys
have done historically right we know they're all
super good but amazing when we talk about uh
hikaru and and maxine we see them very very
close within one in terms of their all-time best
and three minute puzzle rush now remember why are
we why are we choosing three minutes to show here
fans because puzzle battles the only time control
we have currently is three-minute chess that feels
like the best way to get everybody an opportunity
to get a quick puzzle battle versus someone and as
as the popularity of puzzle battles has continued
to grow we are working on more time controls
five minutes in other formats but right now
three minute puzzle rush is the most direct
comparison to a puzzle battle match up
as far as what numbers these guys are capable of
putting up and there you have it in front of you
right ray robson and demetrius they're in the high
60s which is just like mind-blowing right um but
uh anyway and then we've got everyone else there
kind of kind of a big drop but but still very very
close and uh and yeah so all right well i think
i think we're getting set here to start um if the
if i'm if i'm following our run of show correctly
welcome everybody again if you're just tuning in
we've already got more than 500 of you on youtube
what's going on over here on twitch we got a few
thousand almost four thousand it's gonna be quite
the day today so don't go anywhere and uh i think
the matchups are are getting set to begin soon
maurice now danny i gotta tell you i i did this
commentary earlier in the week i was watching
you and amman do your thing together struggle
through those puzzles yeah i know i know but let
me let me say doing commentary on puzzles is the
hardest commentary for them like it and doing and
that was survival mode it wasn't even super fast
trying to to do this to me it's like i'm in
virgin territory i'm coming in and saying
i'm gonna do three minute puzzles like
they're gonna be going by like that like so
super duper quick and that's what we're here for
is to see the speed but it's going to be hard to
actually comment on a puzzle because the plus
is going to come up you're going to say i think
it's bit and then they're going to have solved it
and they're gone so it's gonna be intriguing to
really try to figure this out how to actually
do good commentary when things are going this
lightning fast be a blur in front of us agreed
totally and i can already tell you that last year
um i think i had the call of the final with with
robert if i remember correctly and it was it was
exactly as you described in fact most of our uh
edutainment for the fans really came after the
puzzle battle run was over we could say hey let's
go back to that one critical puzzle you know that
that either won it or or blew it for the guy right
because um right now i can already see that uh and
we're gonna pull it up here for everyone in just
a second but the puzzles are already rolling and
um these guys are solving a mile a minute and here
we go as you can see we've got ray robson versus
eric hanson and unfortunately for the canadian
he's already dropped a red x right in front of us
never good and so far behind as well i mean this
yeah 26-18 that's that's a big lead and ray is
known to run up the score badly i mean you saw
his number as a big record how can you just you
just glance at the chess board and see what to do
instantly and these these puzzles are the exact
same puzzles they're seeing right because it's
well and some they've seen before and it sounds
crazy because we have more than 75 000 puzzles
just above the 2900 level let alone i mean there
are so many puzzles in the database but but these
guys um a funny story maurice i'll share because
you probably weren't following this closely in in
2018 and 2019 when we first launched puzzle rush
it was so popular that guys like ray robson
and demetrius basically forced us to to redo
our algorithm that found high level we'll call it
the 2800 plus puzzles because there were about 10
000 at the time and they memorized them and and so
they basically broke they broke the puzzle rush by
by memorizing the puzzles and at the time
spicy caterpillar was actually an anonymous
user no one knew that rey was spicy caterpillar
and i made him i made him go unanimous because i
said hey man you got to take the heat off me like
people have no idea who you are are you cheating
what's going on so we made his ray robson account
basically retired and made this his public account
because he was just he had blown everybody's
minds with the scores he was putting up cleanly
but through memorization it was nuts yeah even
that's extraordinary when you think about it
right 10 000 puzzles to have that down on top
i mean the fact that he's a 2600 grandmaster
does help because he can you can memorize and see
great moves at the same time as well but there is
definitely an art to solving these puzzles quickly
if you've never seen them before and i mean
just to just see them instantly have the reflex
action to see exactly what to do it's it's
incredible it's just incredible you see there
that already eric is done you see three three
strikes ray's just crazy i mean a train let's
let's jump over to another one i i pulled up
i think we've got um okay we got oh wow look at
this we got zhong and neroditsky with four this
is coming down to the wire oh nerdisky just
misses third never mind jung won i'm sorry
wow brutal brutally are any of them still
going i'm gonna check the other tabs looks like
demetrius did take care of christopher you
with a 54-43 score our our nakamura mvl
one didn't quite load we'll get on that but you
see ray putting up a 57 not his all-time 69 but
as you and i were describing maurice i mean we can
go back what was the one that really had me just
blown away i'm gonna try to find
it real quick here we had this uh
one of these where he just he just absolutely
just crushed it without even being able to
rook a2 one of the ones he solved i i never i
can't even find it i guess we if we wanted to
we could go back to uh mr mr um hansen and see
where he got a few wrong but okay before we do
let's just bring up a recap of what the scores
were in round one um this is where we stand
any surprises to you other than the fact that
apparently hikaru and nbl didn't manage to get
their match off the ground i got a phone ringing
in the background to deal with one second but
um this there are running right now maurice so
let's just tune into that because this is whoa
hicaro misses his first puzzle and we
have a super tight race at 36 a piece
okay wow i hey one of the things about this
everyone is that even though hicaro has missed
one it kind of doesn't matter as oh now maybe
it does because now you got to slow down you've
you've made that second strike right but in
this particular situation the high score is
all that matters remember that so even if you
missed two along the way but we see hikaru
ikaro misses third so not his best start here mbl
actually already has this one wrapped up at 41
and uh and we've still got a minute to
go but he should try to go remember the
the scores matter as far as what you're able to
put up and so nbl should not just give up here
even though he's already got this first round
in the bag yeah just just extraordinary to see
you know the thing about this is when you
are doing these puzzles what when you mess up
there's something in your brain that just just
kicks you for a second that you feel terrible
even if it's just one even if it's just right
you're just like damn i didn't want to mess
up that one and then when you mess up a second
time then you feel all the pressure because you
know the third mess up and you're done so that's
really what this is about you got to get into flow
and as your flow is just going you you you don't
care if you mess one up because you're like no
problem i got the confidence that i'm not going
to mess up again that's the top top level guys to
be able to pull that off but psychologically it's
brutal when you're trying to solve these things at
that rapid pace no you and you make a great point
about that second strike is really where you know
you start to see the you know the momentum shift
because with one strike you don't slow down an
inch but a second strike and that's really exactly
what happened to acaro as we saw kind of his
his run there and when he got when he messed up
on 38 he messed up right away on 39 so all right
so now we're going to bring up the scores again
the first round is completely in the books uh
the technical difficulty there slowed down recaro
and mbl but it's actually maybe not a bad thing
it allows us to focus on that marquee match up so
no surprises um necessarily maurice other than i
guess uh mbl right the one that we said was a coin
flip putting the pressure on naka to start things
off absolutely absolutely that's a big deal but
you know what we've seen naka before let's be real
naka is the kind of guy who when his head is
literally in the lion's mouth that's when he says
okay things have gotten interesting now now it's
fun now it's fine naco just seems i call him hydra
you cut off one head two more grow it's just the
way he is so i'm not worried about him he's the
one guy you know if you're if you're down call him
over because he'll say look we're gonna make this
come back and he means that he's got ice water in
his veins absolutely and and he i don't expect him
to go away after the uh the the first start and
and i actually think that the score that mdl put
up 40 47 is probably what we're going to see all
day between these guys is a score in the mid 40s
um that uh and you know who gets the better of
it obviously will depend but all right here we go
we've got our next round underway between mvl and
hikaru and i think we'll keep it right here given
that we we didn't give them the attention they
needed at the start but okay we've got both sides
solving away hikaru about a puzzle maybe a puzzle
and a half behind mvl maybe not he's caught up
all right we see them just these are the easy
ones we're just winning pieces uh pretty readily
checkmates directly as well uh there you see
a nice little checkmate going on just a little
bit behind it looks like is mvl at the moment a
16-15 score as they're just rocking these puzzles
one of the problems with the with the puzzle the
easy ones no problem but what sometimes you think
it's easy and it turns out that there was a small
wrinkle and those are the worst ones by the way
i hate when that happens in puzzle rush you're
doing a puzzle your solution is good but it wasn't
exactly the perfect solution and you you get
angry at the the game for throwing you a puzzle
that had a couple of good solutions but one was
just better than the other yep i i i think that
that's one of the ones that that really leaves a
mark when you feel frustrated that you feel like
you found a winning idea but like you said it um
it's not good enough not good enough right um look
at this naka showing numbers now two up will he
keep the two-point lead as he's just whipping out
these solutions uh he's streaming yes but he's
not talking yes yeah he knows he's up against it
usually naka is running his mouth uh saying some
stuff chilling bobbing his head there is no head
bopping and no talking right now well let's
let's take a listen in on hikaru because of
what you're saying this is not the normal
stream de caro you're right he is zoned in
wow that was a tough find he's not even talking
no he's not talking he's not doing
this he knows who he's up against
wow and he hasn't missed yet still on a 44 score
wow i just okay i'm gonna try
to say i would have found that
like this is a tough one and he knows it okay
oh my gosh this is tough
check wow that's nice he almost messed
it up but he found the skewer at the end
um
look at that we missed that didn't he
notice the message being sent maurice
a 48 score higher than what nbl got in
the first round he's back i told you
okay this one oh [ __ ] ah i want to get 50 ah
not good whatever whatever it's still good it's
still good it's still good whatever still good i
wanted to get all right we'll come back that was
funny you see the frustration of him not getting
50 which is his all-time best in three-minute
um let's see what happened in the other matchups
looks like uh ray took down eric hanson again
with a 56-40 score not his 57 maurice but a 56
pretty good we see that uh jeffrey young took down
oh wow we i think next round we've got to give
some focus here i also know donna is streaming but
if i'm not mistaken that's two rounds that
have been super close between these two guys
um oh wait maybe it didn't refresh maybe it's
possible that this is actually the score from the
previous round i think that's actually more likely
um because uh as we as we go back to the observing
the observing tab i think i think
up nope we lost it my bad on that
we've uh we will we'll try to make sure that
these uh these are being refreshed properly but
this was the score from the first round and if we
bring up those scores from the second round here
they actually tied look at that 43 a piece that
makes sense sooner or later people are going to
tie in these they're going so quickly and there's
a number of opportunities but we see we do see one
dominant match and that's ray just
racking up numbers against eric
this this will this is not he's not going
to catch him i mean this is just not going
to happen yeah i mean eric eric is um obviously a
super strong grandmaster right um and uh you know
i think i think otb chess level maurice these
two guys would be very close i think hanson
maybe maybe ray has uh a bit of an edge on on
on eric these days but when it comes to puzzles
ray is the reigning puzzle battle world champion
for a reason right and uh eric is a bit of a bit
of a streamer kind of wild card right we know
he's super capable but he already knew taking
the 8th seed that he was going to have an uphill
battle against the beast the beast known as spicy
caterpillar look let's be real and later on my
show my twitch stream i'm going to talk about this
the reality is puzzle solving as we said
is puzzle solving that's that's a skill set
it's only one aspect of chess and you can see
players you could magnus could go against the
best puzzle solvers in the world and lose and
you'll say wait but he's magnus carlson he should
be able to dominate at everything no that's not
how it works it doesn't work like that in sports
it doesn't work like that in chess there are
specific things that you can do well and magnus
doesn't need to speed solve puzzles when he is
whooping on you in a chess game he doesn't need
to do that he just needs to see the move when he's
playing and go i see the move i just may not be
able to do the mouse thing in half a second so
that's the reality of it so we let's not compare
chess ability chess abilities and and think that
somehow this is reflecting that because they're
able to do the solving of the puzzles faster
where do you think i mean that said obviously
you love puzzles we know that puzzles can be very
beneficial for someone's chest so where would you
feel that line crosses like people should spend
time solving puzzles because it develops pattern
recognition and these tactical patterns occur in
their games so that you get the dub right but but
then there's like the line of now you're solving
like compositions and things like that like where
would you feel most people need to get as far as
their puzzle rating or puzzle understanding not
not to become a specialist but to you know
maybe reach like the master level in chess
look this is a very different thing when you're
talking about numbers uh in in puzzle rush
it's it's the quality of the patterns of that
you're solving not this necessarily the speed
at which you're solving it puzzle rush is a lot
of fun you're instinctive you can see these ideas
very quickly but the the greatness of puzzle
rush to me is the variety of puzzles you're
seeing right between great numbers different types
of tactical situations you're not you don't know
you're looking for a queen sack right now this
is about pins right this this is all interference
tactics puzzler says we're going to give you
us an extreme variety of different puzzles
and if you've mastered all these ideas then when
you come to do puzzle rush you'll do really well
especially if you practice so you can go faster so
to me that's really the greatness of puzzle rush
the more you can solve it's an indicator of the
work you've put in away from puzzle rush right
and that it's the great test it's the great test
for you to see if you can see the tactics you're
supposed to know that's it that's a great way to
put it i think the uh okay well before i we could
talk chess and puzzle philosophy all day but these
two guys are probably our closest first round
match up everyone if you're tuning in look at that
scoreboard we saw jeffrey jean got the better by
only two in the first round at 45 then they tied
but now donya is up by three with only 30 seconds
left so this is the both players with two strikes
here maurice a lot of nerves on the line here
absolutely a single blunder could cost and right
now we see he has slowed down has done he doesn't
see the next move yeah i i don't see him making
another move as jeffrey has just caught up to him
the same puzzle same puzzle and jeffrey
knows it he's solving it blown by him is he's
he's just he's just not moving what's going on he
won he's won donya couldn't make another move what
a comeback that was extraordinary he did he could
not find another move but does that make any sense
it doesn't make any sense it almost seems
like it was white to move and i wonder if uh
i'll do the thing where we give a hard refresh
i want to make sure before we give any opinion
that that's indeed what happened yeah somehow
donya oh danya missed this tactic and we just
hadn't seen the third x that was why donya played
bishop b2 maurice instead of bishop g1 and rook
h6 which was the answer that jeffrey found if we
go back to this puzzle here everyone look don you
played bishop b2 over there on the right but the
move was actually bishop g1 king h3 rook h6 check
and then rook takes h2 with a skewer so we were
we just weren't seeing the third x but actually
and that cost him what a comeback as jeffrey
came from behind to find the key move in that
puzzle and that's such a good point he
won he played bishop to be too thinking
i mean he's a great player but he thought this
is going to work because the rook is cut off
right positional idea a great positional idea the
king has to move over to h to the h file the rook
goes over to the h bar and the other rook drops
into c2 that's what he thought was was needed but
jeffrey instantly realized i get a skewer with the
beautiful bishop to g1 that that was boss and that
is what won him this round pretty cool pretty cool
great crazy stuff and uh and yeah we see that it
means jeffrey jung leads their overall battle if
we bring up the scores by a total of three puzzles
he won by two in the first round and then by one
there and the way the scoring system works if we
have the ability to bring up a format card for
that we'll we'll work on that but the scoring
system is each round is worth a certain amount of
points um and uh but you also keep track of the
total amount of puzzles solved in case we come
down to a tiebreaker uh meaning the rounds are
split so um well one when we did miss maurice is
clearly hikaru tsm hikaru as he's known has has
made his comeback proving your prediction correct
he's now up two rounds to one or if you just look
at the total amount of puzzles he's actually
up significantly he won by 14 in round two and
then he just won by six in the third round right
there did i say hydra what did i say you cut off
one head two more show what's it what are we going
to score now first round the head was cut off what
happened two more group the guy is just a beast
he is never losing confidence in any situation
it doesn't matter what and yeah he's showing his
stuff right now well it's why the fans love him we
see he's uh he's streaming right now to about 22
000 of you over on twitch.tv slash gm hikaru so uh
and he's head-bopping from what i can tell he's
head-bopping he's eating actually the snack i
mean i mean this guy's looking this is the hikaru
we're used to he's probably going to start talking
in a moment as well because he's just he's just
such a confident baller when it comes to chess and
the moves look at this like blur finding tactical
ideas i mean just incredible in his mouth skill
danny i think i would get a hand cramp if i try
to move this fast i mean literally i might have
to get a massage i call in call in the physical
therapist please as i try to move this fast
because this is ridiculous how he just blitzes
through moves brain to hand to screen just
incredible it'll throw your back out to move
that fast as they say right i mean i'm too old
for that an old an old chess injury coming back
to bite me uh if i move that fast so i agreed
with you and let's listen in to hikaru and see
what he's talking about he does have one strike
against him though so he's that's kind of annoying
because he don't want to get that second strike
and they're just picking off pieces here the queen
in trouble going there he has to be mindful so he
can win the rook because one chance of winning the
rook on the other side this looks like a mating
attack against the queen there great and now he
should win the queen in this position there you go
and now just realizing the check
will just pick basic tactics is 101
as he's real any alignment that will just lead
to to winning pieces as pieces drop off simply
incredible now he's got to find the right place
so that that one was annoying that was annoying
to find the right spot for your
king that is not a typical pattern
and and that's what puzzle rush will do to you to
hurt you because you got to find the exact spot
for your king what what's the deal i'm trying to
win and you're telling me i got to defend properly
so that was that was definitely annoying for
him and now we see nbl missed his first one over
there too but but yeah no that those are the ones
that come back to buy you and right now we've got
a dead tie here 39 a piece with less than a
minute and this puzzle is annoying this puzzle
by the way you have to be there's a king issue
again this one's tricky there it is there it is
so we see we see in that one there that
hikaru made an error based on the king
the placement of his king on defense he did
it twice now is that something to read into
where he makes mistakes not not quite but we
see that when it's just a kill puzzle when
it's just going destroy he sees instantly
right that kind of puzzle can slow him down
no it's a great point and we see by the way mbl
still solving with five nope now no time left but
he makes it to 44 regaining five total we'll call
it puzzle points uh against icaru as he won that
one by a spread of five so so you know he carries
still seaming in the driver's seat like you said
maybe he needs to put his foot back on the gas
there with uh with uh with that round but um
but mvl strikes back and on the scoreboard we
actually see that it's tied two games a piece
or two rounds a piece with with hiccaro having
the two puzzle lead uh total they're 16 to 14
as far as the difference between them if you don't
mind can you pull up that puzzle that he can't
miss that last one yeah let's do it i'm there
right so in this position he played rook d2 yep
and bishop check on on g8 was played so in here
i'm actually surprised he missed this one because
by taking the bishop which is what he
did he allowed the idea of queen f7 check
you can actually make the move so he he took
this piece which now he allows a typical pattern
that he knows in his sleep this check king h7 it
doesn't matter if you go to h8 right he's gonna
check and it's gonna go f8 f7 all day it's just
a draw right so he allowed this what he had to
do was play king back to h8 and force the knight
to displace itself and that's prob and that's what
mvl was able to do and find that solution so in
this position you have to go back to h8 and force
the knight to displace itself with a check on f7
this is not what you want to do here and now you
can start checking with with white the first check
and your second check with queen to h8 but after
queen h8 king to g6 there are no more checks 95
of them by queen takes on e5 and that solves the
puzzle so i'm that one i'm actually surprised he
kind of missed that one is you could you could see
the queen of seven queen f5 pattern right and so
for him to take means he was somewhat distracted
but it's funny because obviously mvl won the won
the line but if we go to mbl the right side it's
actually one of the few that nbl missed too so
for whatever reason that pattern you missed that
one too yeah for whatever reason it caught them
both by surprise and we see mvl's red x he he got
he got this same puzzle wrong and i admit i
wasn't following it in real time maurice i
i don't know if he missed it with the
same move but i'm gonna guess he did
and and that he also failed to see to see just
the the drawing pattern so funny stuff you saw
we saw carlo kind of say there at the end that
he felt panic because of the time he was like i
thought there was 20 seconds instead of 40 seconds
so i knew i needed to push and that's a big part
of this right is knowing the clock management
making sure they don't miss tactics that they
should otherwise get so well given danny your
point you just made is a really good one given
10 seconds given five seconds you can look
and say wait the guy has this check okay
and then the pattern just comes in your head
once i saw queen f7 the rest was easy right
once i just got like why are you taking the
bishop right but when your clock is ticking
my clock's not ticking i'm just chilling talking
with you about puzzles so it's a lot easier from
the side for sure and uh and well we're gonna have
a close finish here at least in a couple of these
matchups right we know we know ray robson is doing
his thing we've seen uh demetrius a lot of poulos
doing doing his thing is the two seed is there
is there rematch of last year inevitable or will
someone disrupt it but uh if you're just tuning
in don't go anywhere this is the puzzle battle
world chess championship you can watch on youtube
and twitch chess tv and thanks for being here
all right the next rounds are beginning we've got
hicario and nbl queued up i'd say we stay right
here with these two household names one of them
is gonna go one of them is going home right now
and here we go we have on the right we have the
old puzzle though we're not queued up on mvl's
puzzles so we need to see what's on the right
oh yeah yeah yeah that's a that's a weird issue
let me i'll give it a hard refresh and that'll
that'll bring it up there we go now they're both
synced oops it switched tabs though we've got uh
we've got a couple technical difficulties here
jeffrey jiang and hikaru are not playing
each other that's a good bug to note um
i'm going to try to find the match up as jeffrey
zhang and donya are playing each other wow the
eu lot of provost matchup is also very close but
okay we'll need to redo the uh we'll need to redo
i'm just going to go do it myself we'll go find
it in the watch tab and bring up picario and mdl
and restart this thing if i'm glad
you're in charge of this because i would
the fans would be sitting there for 30
minutes if i was trying to figure it out
yeah well i'm gonna i'm gonna switch over here
to zhong and naradiski because we can't seem to
get that one the hecaro mbl match up but okay
um all right this was a close one as well uh it
looks like it looks like jeffrey has the big lead
right because he's up three to one in the match
but the score is very close this score
done is coming back which unfortunately
it might be too little too late let me
try one more time to find the hikaru match
see if we can get this thing working there we
go 38 34 took a little bit of bouncing around
so but but this well we need to see the score
at the top there we go yeah we've got 39.37 oops
car was shaking his head in frustration
we we never know what that means exactly
but he's gotten one wrong you got one wrong early
mvl got one wrong early look at this number 41
to 40 42 to 41. they are whipping out the tactics
and now he carried with the slight two-point lead
and and mvl getting his second strike that's
huge psychologically there right the fact that uh
oh hikaru has the second part as well we just
saw flash up this is anybody's match right now
somebody does not want a blunder with only 20
seconds left this is what has come down to look
at this weird tactic where the rook is getting
trapped with knight e6 and there's a fork no
matter whoa what b3 wow i have no idea how that
puzzle ended but incredibly hicaro gets it mbl
is out with three strikes and hikaru hikaru
is going to be moving on to the semifinals
with just by the hair on his chinny chin chin
that was a great battle between the two of them
and that puzzle you see this kind of puzzle
this is the one you hate to have in puzzle rush
one this is one of the types i'm going to
tell you straight up hate to have because
for me i love it this is something you could be
instructive and show you maybe on my twitch stream
not a regular tactic position this is a study how
do you trap the rook yeah this is nuts yeah this
is so annoying you know the rook is the problem
but how do you do it exactly this this is correct
this is correct i think knight e6 has to be
the move because otherwise rook at five happens
yeah i think it was an error on the board
to yeah because it had to be this and then
the point is it takes here we have a fork yep
look at five we have a four night square rook
that that that the correct move looks
to be f4 after rookie five yeah and then
and then on here that's where the puzzle ended
the final move is b3 get out of here b3 and black
is in zug's bomb look at this unbelievable you're
not threatening king f3 it's the fact that black
has no move black has no move that's that's a
beautiful finish b3 and black can't play king d7
or king f7 because of the forks on either side and
the rook is trapped black can't push the g pawn
because you'll take up assad and you're still in
zug's bomb that's crazy again if king f7 knight g5
if king d7 knight c5 this is one of those geometry
lessons this is one right out of the grand master
maurice ashley playbook right i mean this is like
i'm telling you this this is what my stream comes
to expect something nasty like that and it's
all about seeing your opponent's possibilities
not about seeing your own and here mbl try to
bully his way to the finish which is what you do
when you want to finish off a tactic but he left
the e1 square open for the rook and that i mean
that's extraordinary idea and to think that that's
the only way for white to win this position that's
the other beautiful thing about it you got to
give up your g pawn chaser rook to the open board
and then in the last move play b3 and cut off
its one escape square you hate these in puzzle
rush that's like seriously what kind of people
saw these were the kind that we were solving
in puzzle survival on tuesday which felt a lot
calmer because you had time to you know to make
sense of it all right but yeah again mbl's puzzle
battle world championship goes home on the move
king of three everybody if you're just tuning in
rather than the move b3 which again you can hardly
hold it against the man so all right where did
we finish after round one who's moving on this
is our bracket ray robson with a measly 50 point
uh victory no you know whatever not a big deal um
oh my god yeah it's he's good and eric hanson
is one of the you know he would he would wipe
the floor with me um i'm not sure i've ever lost
10 in a row i.e um signed the adoption papers but
he's very good so that tells you what ray is
capable of as a puzzle specialist hikaru goes
to the semifinals by a four point spread over mbl
demetrius latapulos not quite ray robson numbers
but but pretty a pretty big difference there of
course sometimes sometimes it feels unfair to look
at it like this to a youngster like christopher
you maurice right where he obviously is is very
good in the end it looks like oh man that that
wasn't good right i'm sorry i have to object
i have to object demetrius's numbers uh look
fabulous i mean his top score was 57 just like
ray his bottom score was 58 was 48 okay one less
than rey but then compared their other scores i
see 254s i see a 53 where ray only got a 51. i
think their total is just a hair's breath apart
in terms of total puzzles well and i'll
also a different view on that scoreboard
look at christopher u's numbers if christopher
had played almost anybody else in the first round
he might have been moving on look at those
numbers except right exactly the reason why
you see that differential at the top is that
eric didn't perform to christopher used level
i mean christopher you versus eric would be total
domination by christopher easily so that's why it
looks more competitive but to meet demetrius and
rey again if we add up those numbers i'm gonna say
that they're almost i mean it might be just i'm
gonna say three points off for ray i'm going to
say ray was maybe plus three and then the closest
match which we did cover we did cover closely a
couple of times but obviously there was a lot
of star power in that round so we apologize if
donya and jeffrey didn't get the love they deserve
because wow that was the match up that that uh
looks like it could have gone either way with
jeffrey just that much more consistent right
just a couple more consistent in a couple rounds
and that's why mr zhong sends dania nerodisky home
although i believe donya is still streaming so if
you guys want to head over to twitch.tv slash gm
nerodisky and give him a follow he'd appreciate
that all right so where's our bracket before we
take our first break of the day we've got ray
robson versus hikara nakamura omgs are snaps i
don't think we're going to be focused anywhere
else in the next round and of course we've got
demetrius and jeffrey so i know i mean i don't
mean that in a bad way demetrius and jeffrey
also a very very powerhouse matchup but hikaru
versus rey can nakamura uh stand up to the beast
we we know that it's a difficult thing but hikaru
has said many times ray is the best puzzle solver
in the world and i think hikara will will give us
a show but but that's going to be a tough uphill
battle for the uh the creator of the year in 2020
so all right don't go anywhere maurice and i will
be right back with more puzzle battles on today's
show and uh we'll be back in just a few minutes
so
and we're back moved on to the semis we are thanks
yoda for showing up apparently i'm going to say
it that way and either way we've got grand master
maurice ashley here we're doing the best we can to
just not fall out of our chairs as these amazing
puzzle specialists and speedsters blow us away
with chess.com's puzzle battle world championship
maurice you made some amazing observations at the
break so let's bring up the scoreboard that we had
you you noted that not only did christopher you
put up the kind of score that would have had to
move on against almost anybody else but demetrius
was actually more consistent than ray in a lot of
ways if this does end up being a rematch of last
year's final well i have an explanation but if we
just look at the raw numbers it's different if you
if you had the battle happen between demetrius
and rey round one 57 the ray 54 to demetrius
ray wins round two 56-48 ray wins round three 57
to demetrius 54. demetrius wins round four he wins
and round five he wins he would have won three
out of the five rounds we would have made an
extraordinary comeback three to two against rey
the total score however raised up two points what
happens there that's something i'm glad you asked
that because we mentioned it earlier and um and i
i i didn't didn't have the full information at
the time so the scoreboard is meant to reflect
the total difference between between um every
round so actually ray would have won despite
demetrius scoring or let's say winning three out
of two rounds it's the total amount of puzzles
solved the only reason we saw a 10-0 score at some
point is because for competitive balance and to
prevent a runaway if rey wins let's say by 22 in
a round he's capped as having only one by 10. so
the way it works is every puzzle matters and
that's super cool because as we dive in right now
to the next round and we've got ray and recaro
rolling it means that even if you're out of it
maurice right you see the guy at 54 and that's
frustrating because you're at 46 you should still
keep solving because every puzzle counts in the
end so uh there are it's like twin positions on
both sides it's barely any difference as i look to
the left and to the right the puzzles look almost
exactly the same although now all of a sudden it's
not going who's taking the lead on the right of
the screen as you see the difference in the two
puzzles but but here's ray ray's back it's crazy
and what's where it's gonna show the difference
of whether hikaru has it today right to shock the
world and send ray robson the defending champion
home it's going to be in those late 20s rounds
because what ends up happening so right there in
the mid-20s ray is still operating on basically
memory right and and hikaru has to start solving
it in a different way at that point and that's
usually where you see it now that said picaro is
hikaru is doing his thing right now but he did get
one wrong that's the other thing is rey hasn't
from from what we can see has no mistakes so
the pressure is on hikaru with a bunch of time
left 142 left on the clock and you see that a
second error has occurred and now the pressure is
completely on because a mistake now and he could
end up with a terrible score a third mistake is a
horrible score so you see he's pausing he doesn't
want to get stuck on like 30 and ray racks up
some 50 something number and just blows him with
a plus 10 out the water right away so this is why
you see hikaru can't see it look at his face he
is definitely not wanting to move and that has
allowed ray to take a three-point lead well not
the car was back in business well let's let's
listen in to akara we know he's streaming and
see what his thoughts are as he tries to keep pace
with uh the reigning puzzle battle world champion
ain't gonna be much talking now yeah this is tough
nice he finds the mate although suddenly i look
over to the left i've got two wrong
which makes us really unpleasant
that's the point having already gotten too wrong
and this one you got to worry about those whites
i mean i literally have no idea what the
what is this exactly looks like there's no
possible solution we're we're right there
with the egg yeah what is this i i guess
yeah to be fair ray's having a bad run too
so these puzzles clearly are hard but what
yeah i don't even see how you could possibly win
this yeah i mean no but rook takes oh the queen's
oh my god the queen's hanging wow all the yeah the
queen yeah i didn't realize the queen was hanging
actually oh that's pink yeah i didn't realize the
queen was hanging actually that's really bad yeah
that was really bad that was really bad i didn't
see that either i was looking for the wind
you look up boy you don't look back i
i'm right there with you i was sitting
there on the last puzzle and focused on
where's the mating net which is kind of
the thing that hikaru was saying right
is hey right where's where's the beach
but the queen had been hanging for quite some
time the issue was to just say save your rook
right you make this trade and then you just take
the queen and it's so funny because sometimes
absurdly easy puzzle some of those can hit
you sometimes that hurt because rey has
taken a full 10 point lead karu is feeling the
pressure i don't know as a brilliant player as
he is and he's a better chess player than ray
well i'm sorry but he did make a point that even
ray didn't put up his his mid-50s numbers which we
know he did several times the last round in fact
i remember at one point we were listening to
a car oh and this is as you and i have said
this is this is hard to follow all this but i
was kind of looking at ray's board and he was
stuck on like a low 30s puzzle for a long time for
him so maybe it was something about the delivery
of those puzzles that that caught both players
off guard um where they just hadn't seen him
sorry danny i forgot to mention something
because i said i had a theory about how ray did
against against his opponent in the last round
against eric you notice ray's numbers declined as
he kept playing yeah the last round they declined
he consistently declined as he kept playing
and it's possible when he realized that he was
dominating the match by so much right that he lost
a bit of interest he was just like yeah whatever
i'm just gonna play real quick and you see that's
why he threw in there like a 49 or a 48 i think
that motivation matters so we knew he was going to
blow his opponent out of the water he didn't need
to keep racking up the score so he probably just
was like whatever here you see ray knows he wants
to put up big numbers against ikaru early and you
might see the same thing happen if he starts to
dominate hikaru then he might start declining
as well right it happens right i mean it happens
to all of them because at that point if you know
you've won the match you know you're you know
you've won the match right well all right this
one is not over yet we'll see i we know hikaru
is capable of 49s and 50s right we showed you his
best puzzle rush score in three minute is actually
50 and against mvl i think he put up at least 149
if not if not two um and so the oh wow the next
round has actually started i was not aware of
it and uh and here we go we're at 29 to 26 with
nakamura in the lead and two minutes remaining
all right well the problem for naka he's got a
10-point gap to make up so ray just has to do his
thing every single round just just relax and do
his thing and stay within one or two three points
of naka and they're going to be rounds he
wins and there's going to be rounds that
naka pulls it off so i don't i don't doubt
that nakamura will be able to to win a round
but is it going to be enough it's going to be
bi enough the number has to be so big to make
up a 10 point gap we see here again two points but
it's four rounds that he has has to do it so here
four times three so that's plus
three and he just got one wrong
he just got one wrong and that caused ready
to catch up and now rey has caught him and
overtaking him you see the 41 number but it's
actually a slight lead as rey is just racking
now and naka's lost confidence knocker doesn't
know what to do here he's frozen on a puzzle
and and look at ray just blitzed through the
darkness got two wrong now this is almost
unfair extraordinary this guy ray robson is just
a beast at solving these puzzles quickly 49 to 42.
is this match already over the the spread just
gets so big i mean this is why for those i think
you know there's a lot of fans that follow this
stuff both on on on this channel and on hicaro's
channel maybe for the first time seeing what what
the world champion puzzle solver which is who
he is here on chess.com as far as uh our puzzle
battles go what he's capable of right this is not
the same chess you see where hicaru is capable of
of putting up an adoption against a guy like ray
in blitz and bullet right where he could win 10 in
a row but in in puzzles the opposite is true right
and wow ray again by the way look at the carl's
score 47 is a good score for hikaru right if
we remember last round but but not good enough
against ray robson no not good enough you've got
to be scoring 50s in order to beat a guy like ray
robson if you're not cracking 50 you're not going
to beat him demetrius is going to be the one who
watch out for as as he shows that he can get into
that number consistently but again puzzle solving
is a very different art you you people are better
at things in chess than others you know danny
you and i are opening suck but we could play some
decent middle games and we got maybe average end
games there's certain things that we could do well
that could hit people but we can't do it all well
and naka can't do it all well or at least can't
do it all on an elite world-class top of the line
level like a ray robson yeah well it's funny you
know again we'll tell a story about it because
you know he's likely moving on to the finals and
i think i shared this one last year um
when he ultimately won it all but ray ray
several years ago maurice even before puzzle rush
i want to say when ray was even 16 or something
his coach at the time alex anashuk reached
out and asked me if we could put a little bit
of investment in increasing the number of 3000
puzzles in the database because at the time and
i literally didn't i knew of the talent of ray
robson but i was like are you serious he's like
ray is memorizing your database and i want him and
i'm like what are you talking about he's like yeah
ray is memorizing the puzzles and i'm like there's
like i'm like there's like 5 000 of them at the
time and he's like it doesn't matter you've got
to anyway it was hilarious but that for i think
people just didn't know how obsessed with puzzles
ray robson was until until some of this you know
some of the features here and he started spending
so much time blowing people away i'd be curious
to know how he does on on studies as opposed
to these kind of puzzles he's kind of tactical
how he would do on studies is it any different
john nunn is this is a study solution
guy he's about the studies the unusual ways you
could win right but ray sees straightforward
tactics in a split second i mean the funny thing
about ray is how he always gets in time pressure
in his over the board games right i mean he i mean
we watch him all the time in the u.s championship
and ray's the one you're going ray what are you
doing you're in time for sure why are you are you
looking for that's been a story for ray since he
was very young i mean his trainers kaidonov and
anisha everyone said like ray and it's something
about a perfectionist sort of mindset he has
when he's playing but in in this world he he
clearly trusts himself here there's no there's
no overthinking things getting in time pressure
when it comes to puzzles by the way look at his
car though talk about a round this is a round
now they're tied and rey is stuck well honestly
ray cannot be stuck on this puzzle this is i
think he is oh and he missed it that was that was
bizarre that was bizarre i don't understand look
missing a puzzle is no big deal when you realize
you don't know the solution to something you just
miss the puzzle go on just keep going because
you'll solve other puzzles and you see there he
is back in business he's at 40. despite having
lost the puzzle he's still slightly ahead of
ikaru as the numbers are racking up with only 57
seconds left well we'll definitely go back and
check out what was an interesting rook in bishop
versus rook endgame and it obvious it stumped both
players as we saw but hikaru ultimately got it
right ray did not although as you said one strike
is no big deal and reyes is still in control but
but shout out to nakamura of the three rounds
uh maurice this is this has been the closest
and the best for hikaru from start to finish
yes unfortunately only 30 seconds left and he
he's not gonna be able to run up the kind of must
and he just missed one yeah that hurts and then
that's the psychology of it when you miss one you
suddenly just cascade and now he's gonna slow down
because he doesn't can't afford to miss another
one and here he's seeing his queen is hanging
and black's queen is hanging what's the right way
to play and while he's frozen it's ray who's just
racking up the numbers wow and there it is three
in a row he missed at the end and very frustrated
is naka as this lead is insurmountable it's
gonna be a 27 point lead that this match is done
crazy that ray you know recovered the way he did
and he carries still putting up good scores with a
47 remember his all-time three-minute puzzle brush
bass best is 50. so these are good rounds but
really back in this position here so what happened
ray played i want to bring up both both boards
uh for some reason it's it's not letting me throw
both but either way let's see what did hikaru get
when he played it he ray played rook b7 i think
what was the move i think it's i think it's
because you're gonna play if you bring your rook
back you threaten bishop e3 check that forces
rook d voices the rook to go behind your
bishop and then you play then you swing
your rook along the rank the rook the king
has to come it's cr it's crazy we'd have to
i don't i don't know if our template is set up
for this i'd have to literally click again and
go to the engine room and see what the answer is
because yeah but i this this is a but it looks
like it's it should be winning easier i don't even
understand why this is a so rook b7 is what ray
played everyone but this was wrong even though i
think the only move here is rook yeah no the only
move is that when you swing your rook as black
to the other side then white is able to run to b1
and then you play rook yeah how it works normally
everyone is something like this they try to run
again we uh i know this ending you want the
rook to be on the third rank the white brook
to be in this case on the sixth rank and
you put your rook on the on the fifth rank
that's the technical way of approaching this i'm
i'm breaking our template here just for just for a
second here i know i know i'm ruining the show but
i'm gonna do it because i have to know the answer
so apparently there's a number of moves here yes
but that's why ray got it wrong yeah this honestly
looks like a bad puzzle for us we got we need
to remove this because i've got the engine up
and it looks to me like black is winning
as you and i said maurice because you and
i know this pattern we're not these guys
but we know the pattern right you move them
the only way to stop the thread everybody is
bishop e3 and behind them yep and then you
you swing to threaten the checkmate the only
way to avoid the mate is to run and then this
wins every time so all right i'm i'm doing that
because as always we call ourselves out if it's
a if it's a chess.com problem and that puzzle
is getting removed that was not a fair puzzle
shout out to picaro who's i guess somehow
luckily guessed the move that the computer wanted
which was it was it rook b5 i don't know but ray
played rook b7 and you could see the frustration
on ray's face at the time because he was like he
was like what are you talking about right when
he was here he was like this is winning for
black so anyway all right well so you can't
figure out what what what car was it rook rook
b5 but only when the rook is on the third is it
necessary to put the rook there very interesting
that that is was indeed a mistake but nevertheless
ray bounced back dealt with it and now he's
just he's just got to show any number that's
fairly well no no it's over mathematically it's
over because only 10 plus 10 is possible anyway
so the it's over the car we're just
playing for professional pride right now
100 and a minute kind of knew this coming in he
uh he actually wasn't even planning on playing
in the final championship because puzzle week has
been rolling on this whole time and and you know
we were very aware that the this bracket would
would include a lot of our puzzle specialists
to bring the fun to an end here but we invited
hiccaro and he accepted you know he's uh which is
awesome because he knew the challenge was probably
impossible to send ray robson home um and i think
he even told me privately you know when pigs fly
but he did it anyway and he knew so uh shout out
to ikaro for taking on the challenge knowing that
this was this was probably not a not a feat that
he could pull off so indeed but i'm curious about
what's happening in the other puzzles any other
matches uh can we pull up those matches well
no no the nice thing in the semis is we're not
missing anything finally this is the only match
going on this is the only match going on oh my
apologies i'm not aware of that rule okay that's
great we get to watch these uh directly so so yes
this is just a domination on his part almost ray
could almost just blow anything right now right
just lose both with ease so he doesn't have to
play anymore send in the bench brain like crazy
look like just do whatever whatever whatever
doesn't matter how many i get wrong whatever score
but he's not doing that and he car was
already blown three puzzles and there we go
ray claims the win which is actually uh just
a polite thing to do because he didn't need
to keep running up the score but i am going
to observe that both players missed this one
which was the the top of the third row
interesting i i didn't see which move
they played here everybody but both
players missed this particular puzzle
here yeah it's white to move and win i
mean everybody in the world plays rookie
three in this position yeah and i wonder if
that's actually what they did i have no idea
but okay interesting whenever they get the uh what
else could you possibly play i mean it uh there's
there's no there's just rookies okay after rookie
three it looks like the oh the only try is king h8
i mean there is there is a potential f5 as
well that the puzzle might throw at you but
in this position it looks like uh rook
we have rook h3 why is this nice should
be winning right and the point everyone
is maurice is threatening knight g6 and
almost anything although maybe there's some weird
checks or something so anyway apparently this
was this was a puzzle that i would have gotten
too because those two moves are automatic like
up you're done you know what you know what
could be played there f5 could be played rook f5
could be played against rookie three ah oh back to
the back to the beginning of the puzzle i'll bring
it up the uh oh no but then you still win you play
oh but you you can't because i thought you could
play no you better not check that that would
be a mistake check the king moves and then you
have to find a move yeah now you've got nothing
actually right this may be what happened you'd
have to you'd have to start with rook h3 you'd
have to start with a tree danny in that position
and okay yeah rotation then so here you start with
work h3 with some kind of knight move throughout
like knight takes on f5 right and if queen goes
back to g7 to defend which is the main problem
now you can play rogue g3 right okay maybe maybe
the slip happened right here going too fast
yeah and they missed the sequence not
sure not sure what happened there was
no that actually makes sense and uh again
it's happening so fast that maybe someone
can clip it and solve the mystery but either
way we've got uh we've got our next our next uh
or i think the last round between these two guys
getting set to start in a moment um i think yeah
and uh yeah it looks like looks like we're off
we no throwing in the towel accepting the defeat
graciously you still keep solving and can hikaru
beat ray at least one round everyone's rooting for
one round we'll see what icaru can do oh and ray
misses one that's big that's big if ikaru can
win a round he's going to be proud of himself
so can he do it he's leading right now 15-14
still a long way to go yeah we know what ray
does even when he misses puzzles he he just
keeps solving like he's like uh finding dory right
short-term memory loss and he just keeps swimming
and keeps and keeps winning he's just a beast
and don't put a winning position in front of ray
robson he's going to find the solution uh that
was a that was a fun one but hicaro's still oh
right as i said it i said the car was still
perfect and he missed his 24th puzzle have tied
with how could they do 24 puzzles with in in one
minute i mean a million i mean it's extraordinary
how whoo blitzing through these and icarus slowed
down slightly just a little bit but now he's back
now he's back the score is 29 29. this is tight
right willy karu pull off a last minute miracle
and he's ahead look at that he's up by one
he doesn't have to watch but so does ray
well this this would happen if ray makes any
error along the way hikaru does pull it off
so there are two ways to do it i'm not sure if
ray will make that mistake but if ray messes up
and he's pausing right now both of them
are pausing in this moment oh no no no no
missed it and he came out we saw him kind of
shaking his head like uh ray figured it out
yeah again you know what's fascinating ray's gonna
rack up some number but what's fascinating again
you see ray some of these puzzles and you say
well this guy must be better than the other guy
and it's so not true it's so not true chess is
based on much more than just puzzle solving skills
hikaru has other things a better preparation
his nerves are stronger his endgame technique
is better the things that that hikaru
does better that manifest themselves
in over-the-board chess game or even in blitz
or even bullet you would think ray would kill
hikaru bullet given how quickly he sees solutions
again guys this is a separate skill set you have
different things you need to do well to manage a
chess game and i'm going to talk about this later
on my twitch stream using puzzles to attack when
you do that you you sure you can solve the puzzles
but how do you get the good positions how do you
carry out the attack how do you know how to wait
in positions delay moves because they're not the
right way to attack you can't calculate everything
but you got to use your intuition sometimes to
be able to see this is the right way to play and
your positional understanding this is the right
way to play so these are different skill sets
in order to play chess well but to solve puzzles
you just gotta be ray robson yeah i mean and and
it'll really be on display as we get set for our
next i mean everything maurice just said as we
get set for our next match-up where uh literally
the the puzzle specialist himself demetrius not
taking any way from ray ray's the reigning puzzle
battle world champion but demetrius not being a
title player not even a grand master none then i
am i don't even think he's a feeding master and
again that's not meant to sound degrading at all
it just really shows you the separation between an
overall chess player's skill set everything
maurice just kind of went through right and
positional understanding and then what these guys
are capable of doing jeffrey zhang has quite the
task up ahead so don't go anywhere we're going to
take a very quick break when we return our second
semi-final match-up between demetrius latapulos
and grandmaster jeffrey zhang we'll be right back
and we're back the second semi-final is about
to go down again demetrius lotto poulos versus
jeffrey zhang uh before we jump into it let's
remind everybody of what's at stake because as
we get even closer to crowning uh a champion yet
again we are reminded that it's winner take all so
more than ever it really really matters to these
guys and it was it was our way of taking a look
at this event as a as a fun kind of uh you know
celebration of all that has been chess.com puzzle
week remember that puzzles are free right now
puzzle battle is free normally a premium feature
for anyone tuning in and uh for the for the puzzle
specialist a way to really keep them on the edge
of their seat and motivated to make it all the
way home eight thousand dollars and uh maurice
i mean i know it seems a little brutal right but
you've done you know you've done uh your uh your
events that are maybe not quite winner take all
but really put a lot of pressure on decisive chess
right so this is uh it's fun to see an event that
only one person takes on all the cash right yeah
every once in a while you want to see one of these
events but yeah it is brutal that you come in
you know you could win the kuching big money but
that the competition is going to be so fierce
and you saw ray robson do it against one of the
best players on the planet in ikaro nakamura we'll
see can jeffrey jean conjects pull it off right
now against all odds this is going to be brutal
and i think the money is completely on demetrius
at the moment and he's like you said all in in
being the best puzzle solver in the world can he
get that rematch against the man who has that and
he wants it right he definitely wants it well um
let's uh i think as the match is getting set to
start let's bring up the last score or the overall
scoreboard um and show again how ray did send
uh send his opponents home our our previous
previous matches there we go we got our bracket
again hikaru uh took the challenge against rey
knowing that it was an incredible incredible
battle and hats off to uh to hikara nakamura for
being willing to do that kind of knowing ahead of
time that you know that the scoreboard was going
to be what it was but ray does indeed move on
so he is in the finals and where we are is right
there on the right side of our bracket who's going
to join right demetrius or jeffrey we're finding
out right now here we go well let's be real this
is going to be rough it's going to be rough
we'll see i mean a little solver a puzzle beast
more than the last match i mean it sounds
weird to say because hicaro is you know
super grandmaster and just you know incredible the
strongest player in the field i guess along with
nbl right but but i feel like this one does have
a little bit more of a chance because demetrius is
that much less consistent or at least he has been
historically than ray and i think jeffrey spends a
little more time in the puzzle battle arena than
hikaru normally does but that said i'm with you
demetrius is obviously the heavy favorite i mean
he's ahead right now 23 to 21 and he is whipping
out these solutions just absolutely impressive
what he is doing and you can just imagine
just how much training he does on this and this
alone jeffrey john is trying to become one of the
super grand masters in the world he's studying
his openings religiously he's trying to perfect
his end game technique so when he's getting
pushed to the limit by a magnus carlsen he's
able to defend those those nuanced working pawn
endings you think demetrius is doing any of that
i don't think solving puzzles that's what he's
all about let's solve puzzles although although
take a look take a look right demetrius got the
first one wrong ray sorry not ray jeffrey is
currently up one puzzle so i mean i'm with
you and again i think we kind of know the
final we're gonna see but but i did have this one
circled a little uh look at that a second strike
because one of the things that we know demetrius
struggled with last year maurice was was while he
dominates puzzles and he is an incredible puzzle
specialist he will likely make it to the finals
excuse me going against grand masters is different
than a lot of the people he's battling against on
a regular basis right he i mean he's a chess fan
right so he knows how good these guys are and i
think there's a psychological element where we
did see him stutter a little bit where where
he wouldn't normally because you have an opponent
remember what these guys are seeing is is the same
thing you and i are seeing so he's seeing jeffrey
at 42 right now right he's he's he's seeing it
it's not only that the one thing i will say is
this sometimes you want something so badly yeah
that the pressure is on you and you just and you
feel the pain of that pressure that the weight of
that pressure on you he wants this so badly he's
been training all year to get to this point again
that it may be that it's it's just too much
pressure he's put on himself in order to
execute and you see there he has already lost his
third puzzle so a bad start for him as jeffrey
can add to the numbers and jeffrey messed up
was not happy there plus four to start with
look did you see demetrius get up and walk around
yeah yeah he did he was frustrated but i like that
you said to me uh jeffrey was unhappy there as
we bring up that final puzzle because because he
knows even though you got to be happy with a with
a four-point win to start he knows he needs more
than that to send to me to send gymnast98 username
demetrius um his his real name to send jimmy's
nine-eight home you're gonna need more than a
47 score um and so ray unhappy that he uh that
he did not solve this last one we'll go ahead and
i'll go ahead and bring it up here and we'll we'll
switch over to our analysis tab and uh okay got it
a little um so what was the answer let's go ahead
and analyze it jeffrey right to move obviously has
to take on b6 i mean there's no there's no check
and he took a5 missing queen a7 maurice instead
of just grabbing the bishop what a cruel puzzle
i mean i i don't know that that's that cruel queen
a7 is not that hard to see jeffrey jean should
spot it and the worst part is if this i'm going
to say something to you right now if this was
in game again i want to make the difference
between puzzles and games if this was an
in-game situation somebody plays bishop f6
you notice hey you're attacking my rook on b2
and my other rook sitting on a1 that bishop
needs to go so you're going to take it on
a7 and let the queen come in the way because
that threat is still on the board so bishop f6
he should have noted that but in a real game he
would have easily seen that no question about it
and ripped the bishop off and laughed at such
a blunder but because he's going so quickly
he's playing moves that just look like
they make sense and that cost him big time
and we're going to go right back to our
next round of puzzles here and uh i believe
the players will be getting started momentarily
look at demetrius look at demetrius he's nervous
he this is if he doesn't win this when does
he get another world championship chance
where right where nothing zero this is
he'll have to wait again for next year guys
so he needs this he this is the moment he's been
waiting for the pressure on him big time yep
and the next round is uh getting set
to start here in just a moment and uh
and here we go we've got it up in fact they're
already they're already underway again it happens
fast around here in the puzzle battle championship
um so jeffrey takes a four point lead but not a
happy four-point lead because it could have been
more with that obvious as murray said queen takes
f6 miss but at least it's a psychological you know
a good start for the the young american super gm
and it puts pressure on on demetrius which he
seems to be responding to look at this i mean he's
you talking about 20 puzzles in a minute
maurice he's on pace for a 25 spot
i mean he's dropping these puzzles right
now and they're ridiculous extraordinary
before you can even look at the board the guy's
already solved the puzzle i'm i'm stunned by this
by the way i'm not nearly as good at solving
puzzles that pace but he did get one wrong
he did get one wrong right there so he has
to keep going with energy as jeffrey has
shown that he can he can stay there look at that
almost tied almost still a two-point lead though
and now they're tied and now they're tied they
are tied jeffrey just may be a little bit behind
in the puzzle but still he hasn't missed right
so there's that now i don't think it makes a big
difference until that second strike comes you made
that that point earlier which was a great one but
but also still jeffrey is he's still perfect and
wow and look at that jimmis is struggling with
puzzles earlier than he normally does here
in the mid 30s yes again it's the tension he
wants it so badly he doesn't want to mess
up he needs needs more than anything and
here is jeffrey looking very cool this is the jx
we love when he's playing over the board chest
well he just looks smooth cool relaxed and in flow
and right now he's got that flow going look at him
without any errors flawless so far yep but but
jim is compounding he clearly found a rhythm of
puzzles he knew and now jeffrey's the one feeling
the heat missing his first puzzle at 44. so
and this one's a big one look at
jeffrey paws jeffrey has paused
trying to figure out what the solution was there
meantime demetrius galloped to head and has that
four-point lead so essentially the match is
tied and jeffrey just got his second one wrong
phil it's now again it's a five-point lead so
technically demetrius is up by one now up by two
we'll see if jeffrey can keep it close and again
this is why he was shaking his head everyone in
the last round because jeffrey knew a four-point
swing was not going to be enough to hold off
demetrius consistently and right now it's seven
points i had eight points ahead just blitzing
out these solutions and the battle is over an
eight point lead wow wow yeah an eight point
lead which means he's up by four in the total
match because again if you just tuned in jeffrey
did take the first one by four but wow it's just
crazy and i will say this what we saw there uh
after this puzzle here that he got wrong which was
really almost just a slip of a king and pun ending
missing this move blundering into a draw where
you actually trap your own king and of course
king to b6 was the win but after that look at
the run he put up in those fourth and fifth rows
i swear when he hit these mid-40s puzzles maurice
it was like he had seen all of these before like
that's how fast he was solving them and that's
where you start to see the difference between
rey and demetrius and the others because it was
the opposite for jeffrey he was actually still
perfect and got that king upon ending correct that
demetrius missed but then slowed down big time in
the late 30s early 40s you know when you're
saying a guy has seen these puzzles before
and you have how many puzzles in the database
a lot a lot it's at least 10 000 right
oh no no now it's i mean we're talking hundreds
of thousands total um but um when you get into
the smaller rating groups just because of how
difficult it is to have a quality 2900 puzzle we
see even on shows like this we're going to remove
that rook and bishop one later today right that
it it gets a little harder so it's down to like
it's probably like 50 000 puzzles to be honest but
i'm saying 50 000 puzzles and yeah he's probably
seen a lot of them before how do you memorize 50
000 puzzles that's ridiculous that's ridiculous
but and it means any pattern as they play again
in this round and he's already up six seven
and three by the way this is like neo in the
matrix man how do you move this quickly it's
it's ridiculous it's completely ridiculous
there's other ways to memorize it too and in fact
hans neiman who played last year kind of pointed
this out and it's you know it's kind of working
the system a little bit but he would spend time
in solving puzzles you can actually click on the
puzzle go to the analysis board and see the puzzle
id that allows you to actually look up the puzzle
manually so if you really want to invest the time
and that's what you want to do you could spend
eight hours a day and probably make your way
through thousands of puzzle ids and and get you
know so again like you said this is a specific
skill i don't think demetrius and ray are
doing that i think they're just solving it um
you know comparing to what han said
that he spent some time doing but
but it is possible right and people would say
well why don't you fix that hide the id moments
we're like look we don't need to fix that if
someone's going to spend that much time trying
to memorize the database then good for them right
i don't know what else to say well let's be clear
you may say well you're not really solving you are
memorizing uh listen chess is memory a lot of a
lot of chats is memory not every not every aspect
of chess's memory but if if somebody studies an
opening if mvl comes and shows you the night or
and shows you 25 moves of theory are you going to
say well you shouldn't do that either magnus comes
in and and shows perfect in-game technique because
he studied fundamental chess endings you're going
to say well you shouldn't do that either i mean
sorry of course not right we study chess and
we learn things about the game so that we can
play better when the situation arises so it's
not all memory a lot of this is skillet solving
the guys are showing i was done and now he's got
a five point lead it's gonna be very difficult
for jeffrey jeffrey like you said should
have gotten more points in that easy puzzle
so he had a bit of a padding this
is going to hurt him in the long run
well it shows that he also did enough in that
first round to kind of poke the bear if you will
right and uh demetrius has woken up so shout
out to him because now he's putting on a show
we're gonna definitely go back before the next
round starts and just look at that puzzle number
id number five five two two two
six in a second maurice because
that's an example to me of where these clearly
seen the puzzle before you or i like having not
seen that puzzle like how do you solve that so
fast it was insane but he did and um although now
while he's at 50 he does have a couple strikes
so we'll see how this finishes in the final 30
seconds you also you know it's very important to
recognize that it's one thing to call it memory
as jeffrey has flamed out at 46 and the number is
just going to get too big for him to catch up at
some point but you got to realize also as we see
there an eight-point lead so therefore 12 points
overall this is very difficult now for jeffrey and
two 50-point numbers by the way 57 was that 57-54
so that's going to be competitive with ray in
the finals those are good numbers to be showing
absolutely you can do that now you said this
puzzle look at it how do you solve this puzzle
this was an example i want and again i'm not it's
not we're not throwing any shade memorization
itself is a big part of chess and super difficult
or whatever but it just shows that i was watching
this in real time maurice and he there's only one
move you can see the engine has only one move that
is not even quite plus four for white it's very
close and in a weird game with a queen and rook
versus versus this like in a real game if white
doesn't find rook 3 to d4 maurice maybe black is
the one playing for a win i mean it's crazy right
but white but he found this move instantly played
this move instantly and this move and then the
puzzle was over with bishop f6 and so to me i
don't think it's unfair to draw that probably he's
seen this one before to find that idea so quickly
so precisely well looking for in my eyes was not
a hard move is the the move that i looked at first
but f6 to go away from everything and play rook
d6 next right and to do that instantly that
that's impressive i mean yes it's clearly a strong
move after you see it but for it to be your first
instinct rook h4 gets discarded and then you
realize let me play rogue d6 first before rook h4
right your mind should hesitate somewhere to just
do it instantly that's very well let's bring up
our current scoreboard again if you're just tuning
in we are in the semi-finals of the 2021 puzzle
battle world championship here on chess.com remind
everybody puzzles are free on chess.com today go
play puzzle battle this is where we've been at
ray robson the reigning champion the defending
champion send hikaru nakamura home uh demetrius
latapulos who played in the final last year looks
like he's about to do the same to super grand
master jeffrey zhang and uh on that note we get
set and uh our next round is going to begin here
we go no scores you just put up very important
ray's last two scores did not matter ray's last
two scores he first of all he resigned one of them
not resigned but he stopped it and called it a win
he was up 10 and the very last one he was already
up eight so the last two scores don't count if
this was a what in the matches that count one
two and three if this were a direct head-to-head
match with demetrius i do believe rey would be
ahead yes he would be ahead because demetrius's
43 is not gonna cut it that would sound
that was a bad round to start you cannot get 43
against ray robinson and then you're between that
match you can forget it you're going to die so
he doesn't want to get numbers like that ever or
to get it at the end when when the match is
already over which is not going to likely
happen with ray so that's why we saw him get
up and walk around and be like look i cannot be
putting up that number when i play the one guy
i'm thinking i've been thinking about all year
yep and now again he's oh look at that speaking
of a 25 spot in less than a minute we have it he
didn't quite do it when i first pointed it out a
couple rounds ago but look at this 27 28 puzzles
almost yeah just about 28 puzzles in one minute
but look at this one and just a brief hesitation
i thought he was going to hesitate on it for just
a second and that was that and jeffrey um not too
far behind him right oh no oh and he messed
up with knight to f6 check on that last move
that's this is brutal it's just brutal because it
looked logical but this is going to be the match
as jeffrey cannot move quickly anymore if he
doesn't know without without absolute certainty
what the solution is and here i'm surprised
queen check and queen check again looks winning
and he took a little while there did jeffrey uh
but a five-point lead to annie yeah no it's it's
with no mistakes by the way it's what we what
we expected right but i think as you said we're
we're already kind of talking about the rematch of
last year whoa demetrius does miss one but overall
still in great shape um jeffrey has put up a
couple good rounds you see the scores everyone 47
49 49 is a very good score um it might even
might even actually be tying his all-time
three-minute puzzle rush score we'll
bring that up again um in a bit i forget
three minutes though okay so jeffrey jeffrey jones
best is 52 all the time sorry maurice go ahead
52 all times is best yeah world champion puzzle
rush you need to never see 40 basically i mean you
just you've got to be able to hit 50s consistently
if you're playing for the money and you see here
57 54 by demetrius ray does the same kind of
thing jeffrey consistently will get in the 40s
but it's the 50s he needs to get in in order to
truly win to truly compete not even win to compete
with the top players man that last one that
demetrius solved with queen c8 being the final
i i brought you see my mouse over here everyone
i brought up because i just had to see it again
the mini board of queen b6 and you take the knight
never mind we'll bring it up but that was just i'm
blown away um all right they're done so i'm just
gonna i'm gonna click on it and uh and bring it up
to our uh to our analysis board
here as you and i get set because
so this patch is over this match is over yeah one
round left only a 10-point swing is possible and
he's already up what is he
going in with plus 16 i think
yeah he's up he's a big time and not to say that
once this position is reached it's not obvious
queen to c8 because because frankly it's the
only move for the queen right if you go to c6
then the bishop b5 pins you but it was just the
speed that he solved it with that he had seen the
seen the puzzle before it felt like it was just
bananas to me so anyway all right we'll bring
back the scoreboard sorry i just had had to
show that and entertain my my fan my fan-ness
the fan in me that is just blown away by these
guys and there you go it's a 20-4 overall score
a um a 20 point lead right now for uh or
sorry 16 point lead overall for demetrius
yeah this is this is just too much but look at
rey's numbers and compare them to icarus numbers
i mean ray not ray jeffrey's numbers excuse
me jeffrey would have dominated hikaru in the
head-to-head match with these numbers well and
that's why i said what what i said in regards to
and as the next round kicks off we'll
bring it up as we're talking about it again
i didn't mean it as any shade torre car
who took on the champion's task of knowing
knowing uh that he you know wasn't going to win
this event right but he wanted to do it anyway and
have a chance to go against ray but i i thought
this match would be closer and demetrious is a
little bit less consistent than right at least
at this time that ray has been the world champion
and jeffrey spends more time in puzzle battle than
hicaro does so i i had the thought that jeffrey
might be a guy that could shock us but as it turns
out he's not going to shock us but he is putting
up a score that as marie said would have sent
hikaru home so again you're not throwing shade
hikaru knows it yeah he knows it's not about
solving puzzles quickly that makes you an elite
player it it's about all the other things that are
involved and he has that package you want to be
well-rounded as a chess player you cannot just
solve puzzles and think you're doing something
anybody who sits around and solves puzzle rush
only all day and and think that their rating
is going to get any higher well think again so
yeah that's that's not throwing shade at anybody
hicary has enough accolades and his ability has
been proven time and time again for him to know
that if he sat down against demetrius he would
destroy demetrius in the chesapeake bay demetrius
may not win one game in a 20 literally not one
in 20 despite all this clear tactical prowess
that he has so it's a different skill set and he's
showing that he's a boss at solving puzzles that's
that's we'll see if jeffrey can do
what hicaro did higaro gave us quite
the quite the race in that last round um but
ultimately still fell short to ray but here
jeffrey might be about to take home the
last round between these two it's close
we still got over a minute to go and
the harder puzzles coming this is where
the difference will be seen
one look at this he's up four
yeah he's up by four now only two but still he
seems to be in a good rhythm right now jeffrey
we we got both their eyes on camera he is alive as
soon as we set it close the gap to one and has now
tied it up seriously 43 jeffrey has to stay
consistent he cannot mess up and here he's
paused pause for justice oh wow he did solve it
and demetrius missed his second majors missed it
wow what a close finish here in the last round 30
seconds to go what will happen will jeffrey just
bragging rights at least yeah a little bit of
bragging rights show what he can do and he has
done it he has done it he just missed another
puzzle jeffrey takes a win now can he get in the
50s will he be able to get a 50 spot he didn't
get it any of the rounds so far here he goes
come on jeffrey get a 50. there you go get it
puts puts up the 5-0 you got it he's got 51.
one less than his best score ever you needed more
of those though to be competitive wow no that was
a great a great score 51 for jeffrey zhang his
his not quite his best all time but right there
well congratulations to jeffrey it was a good run
unfortunately as we've said it's winner take all
and we will have a rematch of last year's
championship which we'll break into and
uh and start to preview and talk about here
after our final break before ray robson and
demetrious lot of poulos throw down in a rematch
of the 2020 puzzle battle world championship so
we got 10 000 of you on twitch we've
got i don't know don't have in front
of me on youtube but no matter where you're
choosing to watch from thanks for being here
we will be right back with the final of the 2021
puzzle battle world championship in just a minute
so
and we are back getting set for the finals here
in the puzzle battle world chess championship
but before we get into that a big big shout out
want to remind everybody to head over to twitch.tv
gm ashley i even just i just typed the the command
in our twitch chat i'll do it again just there we
had about 2600 of you on youtube you should also
be subscribing to maurice ashley's youtube channel
and follow him on twitch because uh because big
things right i'm not going to tease things that
are coming to your channel soon with some awesome
special guests you have coming but i'm going to
say big things from maurice ashley's content
creation online this year right indeed indeed we
got a lot of stuff coming it's going to be fun
it's going to be interesting it's going to be
informative though that's the most important thing
of all you know i like to teach danny that's been
a part of my personality my character my mo for
decades now and that's what we're gonna do so
we're gonna talk some serious slashing attacks
some vicious attacks with one specific theme in
mind you're gonna see in this day on today's show
so right after this one i'm gonna give an extra
shout out going off script here because i'm just
gonna say that i personally am a huge fan of the
way maurice delivers his content because he puts
so much work into it and again he's not joking
when he says he likes to teach so much stuff there
is literally if you're if you're on twitch and you
know you've been watching all kinds of other chess
streams this is not like other chess streams you
are going to get better watching these shows
and maurice breaks it down like i guess like
a pro like we would expect of you and you know
who else is puzzle pro ray robson let's remind
everybody what they're playing for here maurice
eight thousand dollars is on the line man winner
no second place prize it's it's cruel we know
okay and uh but it's happening and it's gonna
be awesome brutal um let's remind everybody
of just how close we expect this to be here
everybody in this particular eight player knockout
today was awesome we know that uh and they're
putting up scores that you and i couldn't touch
but ray robson and demetrius lotapulos at the
top with their best three-minute scores being 69
and 68 respectively we haven't seen anyone touch
60 yet today maurice but i will say last year
there was one round where i believe both rey
and demetrius got in the 60s in the puzzle battle
wow well they should be able to pull it off but
look they knew they were going to dispatch the
competition in the first couple of rounds like
you guys got to go but it's now they know
this is it they're playing again it's the
world championship and it's on and they're off
and they're off right now they're already at a
nine and ten score for those of you think hey you
were late where'd you go remember these guys are
solving puzzles in like five they were pretty
much at ten in like five seconds so uh we you
haven't missed much at least as far as the eye can
see and wow maurice this is it 1515 deadlock you
can if you take like the abstract viewers you know
where you like you back up and you make your eyes
look at the whole thing like they're out they're
on like the same puzzle at the same time right and
it's it's wild to see the indeed r and ray just
just came back and took a small millisecond lead
at the moment they're at 22-22 this is just the
best of the best in the world at solving puzzles
showing what is done at this level it's incredible
look at this you can just look at the score and
see how close it is no error so far and as soon
as i said that he messed up and you saw him wince
right there did demetrius when he finally
made a mistake and that mistake has cost him
a number of seconds and rey has taken a big lead
at this level of three points yeah and he's got
a four four point now with one strike also against
uh gymnast9's credit and we see ray is still
again i don't know if it's memorization pattern
recognition memory doesn't matter what he's put in
the time and you see it you see it right here he's
uh he's solving like he's seen these things before
but he's also happens to be a height
2600 almost 2700 feet a player so
he doesn't need to have known it only he also
is a boss of a chess player and he's the world
champion when the world champion puts pressure on
you you cannot let his will that's the imposition
of his will on your brain and that is what is
happening right now is he's got this six point
lead that he's not giving up five point lead
now a second mistake by demetrius and he's made
a third cracked at that moment this is terrible
because rey can rack up a massive score and get a
10 point lead in the first round you see demetrius
is walking around he is disgusted that he got a 41
in the world championship that is not a number
you want no it and you said it you said it best
because it's not even that he lost it's the 41
number right it's the fact that that's a score
that oh and ray ray misses his first there but
that's a score that you just you can't get you
can't get in the finals um as you said it's got
to be 50s or go home and even with ray missing one
he's still going to put up a mid 50 score here uh
in the final seconds yes and well he's only going
to get plus 10 not not plus whatever he can rack
up but he's showing this is almost psychological
hey come take a look at the number i'm going
to put up on you yeah you got to do this 56 a
brutal start for he's got to hope demetrius does
that ray messes up along the way because this
could be over from this very first round yep and
you said it it will be capped at 10 that's the way
the rules work so if that prevents it from being
a competitively unbalanced matchup if it ends up
being a landslide i don't expect this to be the
difference between these two guys all day everyone
but let's uh let's bring up our scoreboard as
i'm going to bring up the only puzzle that ray
got wrong in that very very impressive run of
56 i believe his high of the day has been has
but yeah so this this was the one he got wrong
i didn't see it in real time maurice do we know
which what move he guessed here that was wrong
the best move is knight to d2 which by itself is
just absolutely crazy in this position what is
going on here i mean absolutely just outrageous
that like that makes that move makes exactly
zero sense why would you give away your queen
on a three look at this full combo where he's
92 takes and then queen d6 is is this one
i mean that's that's unfair yeah of course it's
just unfair like what is it that's amazing by the
way by the way you're threading the rook but it's
not clear what else you're threatening because
queen g3 is not a threat queen h2 is not even
mate yeah so so you're so the king is going to
go for a walk and eventually you made it in three
moves it looks like yeah it's made in three yeah
the full combo i i believe uh ray did not see
queen d6 everybody i think he found knight d2
but the full combo is actually rook f3 and then
queen h2 which apparently will win the rook on the
next move so all right mind-blowing stuff we get
set for our next round of these two guys which uh
which will be underway shortly but um wow wild
stuff there in that puzzle i'm look i looked at
that puzzle i thought it was rook g1 and queen
e5 but there's a queen on e2 that just goes
to show how crazy the puzzle was and how easy
it is to mess up in that position i mean just
that's a ridiculous puzzle you got two
queens on the board and you got a sack
yours on a3 so you can play queen d6 what was that
a 4 000 puzzle yeah no it's nuts all right well
now it's on jimmis he's down by 10. in total it
was even worse than that 15 15 as we saw a 56-41
score there for ray robson but all right the next
match begins right now and we'll see if demetrius
lotta pulos can bounce back he's gonna he's
gonna try to put up his best number that's all
he can think this it could be over right now if he
doesn't win this one or if rey adds to the score
you're in deep trouble like absolute deep trouble
but the the key for him is just to stay consistent
as consistent as he can say and the hope that
somehow rey messes up let's be clear if rey
doesn't mess up this could be done already yep
well remember unlike the uh quarterfinals let's
say the the initial round of eight and the semis
this is a 10 battle matchup so we've been seeing
five match up sorry five round match up so in the
finals here we're going to give these two guys
10 total chances so um so let's let's remember
that everyone don't go anywhere right we can
see these guys slip and slide and we know that in
some ways maybe not quite like bullet necessarily
maurice but we have seen momentum be a thing
right so sometimes you know you start off wrong
but if you find it it's like it's like everything
clicks so we'll we'll see what demetrius can do
and maybe find his rhythm here uh before he lets
ray run away with it again i'm going to argue if
rey if rey doesn't mess up it's just ray is ready
the battle is just so close look at the number ray
has now 30 to 29 it's a close score ray could
just stay with him the whole time right and win
some lose a little bit here you need rey to start
blundering ray needs to go down if reiki's being
ray 10 points is just too much so great did
make a mistake oh but as soon as i said it uh
it's funny they both missed that puzzle and
that just shows you the way that they approach
these things guys we'll take a look at this
puzzle when this round wraps up to see what
they both missed but um it shows you that
most the time they're both seeing puzzles
they know and that was clearly one that maybe
maybe uh neither one has had in their book yet
this last one they also hesitated just
a little bit but now they're both at 36
a close score here 37 37 and it looks like
demetrius is taking a slight lead yes he has
he's a little bit ahead in the solving as he's
going ahead just by one he needs for his ego
for for confidence he needs to win a match quickly
and this is one that he has a chance to win
yeah and he's uh he's got three and both sides
seem to be struggling with this series of this
is definitely going to be a lower score
than we just saw no matter what everyone
something about this round which does happen
because the algorithm is delivering them
randomly something about this round has clearly
been harder for them than maybe their previous um
their previous sets i'm sorry danny did you see
the comeback that ray made i know that was nuts
like that he blitzed by him and a third error
with time running down and ray able to rack up
a three-point lead just at the buzzer a three wow
extra and we celebrate already give a head nod
there maurice and uh the uh the big cam shows
he he gave like a head it was almost like a
yup i got this and and while we see these two
guys on camera i'm gonna bring up two positions
for us to look at both the one that they both
missed and then this absolutely nutty one that um
not sure if you saw it in real time maurice i'm
gonna go to that one first this is a good example
of crazy puzzle memorization at least as far as
how quickly he played it it's not just that he
finds the move rook rook f1 but then he instantly
already knew the puzzle that the only winning move
is rook eight to f5 like you gotta i mean i would
be looking at other things and he played this
instantly because now there's no way to deal with
check and mate on the h file and you have to play
it in this order that is ridiculous i'm gonna tell
you right away you don't play that move instantly
yep that's really crazy so that's an example and
that was a by the way i think that was his number
47 being solved everybody so that's that's again
that's that's crazy hard crazy memorization then
the one that they both got wrong i'm finding it
was this one right here and i actually didn't see
what both sides missed but rook takes b2 is the
move yeah so they must have both oh actually i
remember at least one of them now played queen
takes a2 so that was the move they missed you
have to play rook takes b2 because after that
it's an easy puzzle the computer just gives away
its queen and they wouldn't have missed that so
it was this move here that they played queen a2
i'm going to say to you i'm going to say to
you that rook takes b2 is instinctively bad
why because your bishop on b7 on g7 is pinned yep
and maybe it might be captured so instinctively
it's bad but of course it's good nobody's gonna
take on g7 it's a queen you're giving up that's
dumb so you you might hesitate just for a moment
wait i can't take because my bishop is pinned or
somebody might knock the legs out from under my
rook turns out it's all secure you don't have to
worry about anything just take the pawn you're
crushing the player they have nothing to do to
address your bishop on g7 the rook cannot
go to d7 because c2 will hang to mate so
no problem there and can you believe this easy
puzzle is what these great jobs and it's funny and
it shows that they both missed it right so as we
as we get set here for our we're going to get the
third round rolling but yeah they both missed that
puzzle which just shows you they uh they didn't
know right they haven't seen it before now that'll
be added to the old uh the old whatever insane
memory they apparently have and right right before
danny when you think about it because because for
taste beats it was a move you and i would play in
a heartbeat like give me the pawn it's free and
it's not even it's not even the black isn't better
there which makes it even harder right it's the
puzzle is a good puzzle rook takes b2 is the only
winning move but but it's an easy move to make
queen takes a2 so crazy and and they will they
will learn their lesson together on that one but
all right ray is up by 13. closer match it was it
was only a three-point spread there but he can't
keep that up demetrius has to start winning and
i'm going to tell you he's got to win now he's
got to win now he cannot let ray add more points
to this score it's just gonna be too hard to come
back unless rey gets super tired or something
but i don't see it ray could play these for hours
and he does and it's it's why he is who he is
and why he's about to drop like demetrius another
25 spot in the first minute which is crazy and
it was funny shout out to ray because we had some
emails back and forth when you invite when you
invite the reigning and defending world champion
to something and you've changed the format to be
winner take all puts a lot of risk on them right
and so shout out to ray that he was like yeah i'm
game so he was that confident he was like i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna negotiate for anything like
i'm game even though you guys change the format
where i won't get anything for second place so
uh it's gonna be fun here to see how these two
finish in the next seven rounds i like that that's
great that's cause that's called swag i got swag
swag and i'm not worried about who money whatever
i'm the world champion i want to go i got game
and let's get it done right now he is getting it
done although each one of them has made a mistake
looks like on the exact same puzzle again again on
the exact same part we'll have to bring it oh and
ray makes a second mistake so this puzzle here
that i've got i'm highlighting here on the mini
board maurice and i will bring it up um in between
the break of rounds and take a look because
again it shows you how similar how just why these
two guys have to have the best all-time scores in
three minutes 69 and 68 respectively yeah their
hair's breath apart and they see similar patterns
this is what puzzle geniuses do i love these
puzzles i'm seeing flash in front of me and
he's got the three-point lead but we've seen ray
just make a three-point lead look like no point
lead if you start messing up and two mistakes this
is a lot of pressure by the way on demetrius he's
got two mistakes he knows he cannot afford to make
another one but ray also has two mistakes and ray
is stuck not moving at all because he doesn't
want to look at that and and ray didn't make it
his reaction with your voiceover was
perfect he was like what am i doing
i mean obviously it's a big win
because he's up by seven 46 to 39
but he had a chance to run the score up yeah
let's bring it up right there um i'm gonna
bring up the last two puzzles the one that he
missed and then the one that they both missed
it very important to win so that's a big deal he
shouldn't feel bad but he the very important to
win we had to do it sooner or later only getting
39. is ray getting tired that's an opportunity
for demetrius but let me just say if he had won
if he had done the 10 thing because it doesn't
matter how much he hit it's still 10 he would
have only been down three now he's down will
will that haunt him later yep yeah absolutely well
let's see what he missed here um in this position
he played rookie eight now the winning move is
rookie eight but i don't think he played that
oh okay i think he played queen of two if i and
again it happens very fast so forgive me uh fan
but i'm pretty sure he didn't play rookie eight
um i mean he may have played rook c but i remember
the final position was not his work on eight and
so i think he just missed the the first move here
which again understandably that's a very it's a
very hard move to see well i i mean i i saw it
again i'm not on any pressure but i saw the idea
right away the back prank is exposed where do
you put the rook to take advantage of that and if
you put it on the c file the queen can draw back
to d1 and then how do you deflect the queen right
wow then you can play queen f2 on the second move
right right so that's why it has that's a
good point you pointed out that's why it
has to be rook e1 to point out sorry rookie
eight for everyone you have to put the put
the rook and queen together on the f on the
uh the e1 spot which is why this is the only
the only move order to go for okay well but and
then the other one the other one excuse me that
um getting to it i had it i had it somewhere i
think it was right here danny yeah that puzzle
it's easy the reason why it's also easy to mess up
and that last puzzle is after rookie there is h3
aha and that actually was the that was actually
the main line is is the combo is rookie eight h3
and now you got to find the queen in this line
with with queen e5 and rogue h1 after g3 i mean
yeah that's that no it's understandable right
and and again the other one which is the one
they both missed everybody was this with the
answer being knight takes f3 g takes and bishop
takes now when bishop takes a6 you take d2 and you
win here i actually i don't know what they played
um i think that i think the move they played was
actually bishop c4 i saw one of or no maybe one
of them took with the queen but ultimately this
is the only way that wins yep okay oh man not
not a hard puzzle that those two puzzles are not
hard puzzles they saw much more difficult puzzles
than that like light year is more difficult but at
speed sometimes that sequence move order sequence
will catch you they're little things that catch
even the best people and a little thing like the
move order will get you but here we go can he
ride that little bit of momentum that he got
from that win and if he can see if he can
close the gap with ray in this round yeah again
everybody if you're just tuning in where have you
been we got almost 3 000 of you again on youtube
almost 10 000 on twitch but uh yeah ray really
won the first round big time as you can see 56.41
but uh but it's not over we still have seven
more rounds to go here in the 10 matchup final
but this is great for demetrius the
fact that he has won in commanding style
so and and he closed the gap in the last round
that was important close the gap in in round
two says i can stay with this guy i just
gotta stay cool stay confident stay calm i
will make up ground six points with ten rounds
that's nothing to make up it's all about your
confidence that gets it done so let's see if he
can pull it off and right now he's up a point
keeping the flow but it's a long two minutes
to go agreed agreed agreed um in the uh
okay he's still up here in the in the fourth
round 27 25 although he's looks like he almost
got stuck there nope he finished it made his
28th but most of both of these guys are what
he does here he got stuck on that puzzle now
here's ray here's where with the same puzzle
and ray paused for a second as well you saw that
yeah so they pause on the same kind of puzzles
very interesting we should note that anytime
somebody pauses will the other one do the same
in that kind of puzzle look this one the 34th
puzzle he also paused i want to see when ray
gets to puzzle 34. here it is we'll rate pause
here yep and the same thing it's incredible and
the same thing it's like twins they think notice
the difference 35 they both rattle off instantly
so again a lot of this is like they've done
the work right they've uh they put the time in
a mistake and he reacted physically did
demetrius and that has cost him in the next
puzzle as ray closed the gap but it is it's
not it's still three though it's still three
can he maintain it it's a long 43 seconds
left and we see he still hasn't missed one
now he's on no actually no he did just solve
correctly the puzzle that demetrius got wrong
but it doesn't matter he's still down by three
you got to speed up gms98 is about to hit 50.
well speeding up is not he's keeping a great pace
he doesn't have to speed up he's going to hope the
other guy misses but just keep a good pace and
the other guy might slow down himself so here
we have a two-point lead 16 seconds left can ray
make the spurt and it's 52-53 look at the score
it's coming down the wire deadlock six seconds
one point separating them one puzzle oh and
this is his last one but ray runs out of time all
right well that was a boss round for both of them
the first round where two players scored both
players scored in the 50s and a big score that
one of the best scorers either has put up so
unquestionably look at demetrius's trajectory
though he's getting stronger yeah ray had to raise
staying himself he had a one bad round in round
three but demetrius can say look i'm catching
my flow i'm gonna hunt you down dude you only
got a five point lead with a lot of rounds to go
well you made a great point that as a six point
difference which is what it was going into that
round you could make that up just literally one
point at a time right one point around and you
would catch up so we are we are going nowhere
everybody this is going to be a close finish this
was the puzzle that ended uh jimmis 9 8 demetrius
lota pulos's run here after queen h a queen g4
bishop h6 king e7 queen e5 this position here i
don't think he played king d7 i think that was the
mess up um because i remember seeing queen g4 on
the board but anyway either way we know that there
was no mess up to bring up for ray maurice because
ray was actually perfect through that entire round
he was just slower than jimmis the entire time but
ray didn't miss any puzzles and this was the
one i believe jim has played king d8 instead
of king d7 but okay we're gonna we're gonna be
diving right in here moving to the fifth round
any minute um i actually don't even know if
we're taking a break if we're running away
through but i think round five is gonna start
any second either way so let's let's continue
okay but we've seen him show some momentum making
a mistake is not a big deal if you just shrug it
off and keep playing it's when you react to your
mistake when you feel the power of the mistake
that you say oh i get i gotta hesitate
i don't want to do another one of those
but the champions like these guys they make
a mistake and they're able to forget it like
a wide receiver scores a touchdown on you you
know the safety's thinking so what you're not
doing that again that's how you have to play short
memory and in puzzle three-minute puzzle rush
you better have a short memory all right i'm told
we actually are taking a quick break before we
get to the back half and ultimately the climax and
crown a champion here in 2021 for puzzle battle so
we are going to take a very very quick break don't
go anywhere when we return it's the back half of
the championship match between grand master ray
robson and demetrius lotapulos we'll be right back
and here we go we are back with a small lead for
ray robson as we head into the the final the final
set of rounds with me grand master maurice ashley
and uh let's do it without any further ado it's
time for round five here between ray robson
and demetrios lotto poulos let's go it's it's
getting we see demetrius has now won two rounds
in a row right even though he trails overall
he's making headway and i i can't wait to
see what these final six sets bring us so
the big issue danny the big issue is will ray
have a collapse round he did have that 39 score
and as they're about to go off and off to the
races but will he have a round where he just
collapses and gives demetrius a chance to pick
up a healthy 10 like he did against demetrius
that's the hope so demetrius is going to keep
putting the pressure he was down a lot but he's
closed the gap to just five right now can
he pull it down some more and make ray feel
like wait a minute this guy's he's doing it he's
doing it and mess up that's going to be the key
yeah it's almost like the the thing that um robert
and i said and i think hammer when he joined too
about magnus being in the scc and and ultimately
magnus did actually lose for the first time in
the sec but we said it's almost like what happens
when when the champ gets punched right right now
it's been ray in the lead and and jimmis is the
one dealing with the psychological difficulties
but if ray if ray gets put on his heels a
little bit do we see any kind of practical stuff
you know start to creep in right where he clearly
doesn't solve at the level he's capable of so
so we'll see he's rolling that much faster than
ray at this point i'm telling you he's feeling
his confidence level is high at the moment
as he's just whipping out the puzzles but ray
you can expect ray to make a comeback the puzzles
so far have not been ridiculously hard but
ray okay right now unless it looks like
both of them are killing these early puzzles
we're down to a minute 30 right now and it's
plus two there's going to be a puzzle danny
there's going to be a puzzle i'm waiting
for it yeah one that the mess up happens on
we'll see when it happens is right now they're
just playing like the best in the world
yeah and they've they've they've been here before
they've seen a lot of these puzzles even the ones
that they haven't they're clearly in a comfort
zone wow is this the first time we've had both
or two players reach 40 and still be perfect at
the same i think i think so i think so and ray
made a wicked comeback and has now seemingly
taken the small smallish lead but nope there
it is a slight lead again for demetrius he's up
one wow up by one now up by two blink there but
he's just saw i mean monstrously solving these
readings are we about to have two players reach
50 with no mistakes no way no way he's got
it the demetrius got to 50 can ray join him
oh my gosh at all this is what a run we
are watching between these two heavyweights
and i think we're going to see 60. are we going
to see 60 get showed up i think we're going
to see 60. demetrius is on pace for the first
time i think of anyone today to hit a 60 marker
and this is why this guy is so feared
oh and ray misses his first puzzle
that's big that's big we could close the gap
this round he's at 59 and no mistake he made
60. we have a 60 for the first time today but
he does miss one still a big score plus four
cutting the lead to just a single point
incredible what a matchup we're seeing
five rounds in the books a big nugget of 60 and
a one point difference mind this is crazy that is
that is the kind of round maurice that we said
could put ray in the like what happens when the
champ gets punched right because what what's in
his head one he's blown his lead right and two
jimmis is the first one to reach 60 not ray robson
not the defending champ so of everyone who's
played today 60 is not a number you come by easily
by the way how much more impressive does it make
does this make their all-time scores of 69 and 68
right how did they ever do that that was crazy i
mean this is nuts and they're about to go right
at it again it's a one-point difference between
the players that's crazy the score that you see is
the differential that is being put up and rey was
at 13 after the second round there we go he is
stuck on that 13 points and it's jimmis who has
who has won three rounds in a row and dropped the
60. and look at this score right now 15 10 what i
don't know what happened here even though they're
both actually solving what almost looked like the
same puzzle i think maybe not maybe way ahead well
no no ray is now closing the gap but i wonder if
ray was like not paying attention or something i
don't know what happened there at the start maybe
the maybe they're going so fast the computer's not
registering i have no idea i mean they're going so
quick 25 already in less than a minute and and now
they're just in their comfort zone oh and jimmis
makes his first slip up in four rounds everyone
after that slow start you see on that scoreboard
56-41 uh demetrius lotapulos has been has been
the better solver in many ways but but that
was a slip up all right he's still in the lead
though would that slip up could be significant
because two more and he might get frozen out and
ray could add numbers so you see here he's paused
just for a moment because he doesn't want to mess
up and that has cost him he's now down two to ray
the hesitation now down four the hesitation
after you mess up because you don't want to
get the second strike yep now down five i saw for
a second back to four he needs to catch his flow
again raised perfectly in flow and he and he's
solving all of these puzzles like he's seen them
before this looks like a round where ray robson's
work is paying off because i mean he's perfect
he's perfect after 40 and okay right as i say
that of course he messes up commentators curse but
but he hadn't had a single puzzle that stumped
him well 44-41 what happens when the champ
gets punched in the mouth we're seeing it he the
the champ gets stronger i mean the wolf comes out
says no i've got to put back a number i was up 10
and one i was up 13 at one point and the score is
now just one point separating them but wow here
demetrius this is not his round necessarily but
he's got to stay close if he just loses by one or
two it's okay there's a lot of rounds to go but
he cannot let ray separate himself and we see here
just a one point difference i was going to say it
it seems like like demetrius is not going anywhere
he's but he lost he he messed up again though
i didn't see it he just had his second strike
now he's really got to slow down that hurts
and he made his third strike can ray build wow
ray has got to stay focused can he put his first
60 of the day i'm gonna find out he's got five
seconds to solve it and he does do it he's hit
60 with one second left oh my gosh and look
at that head bob he's like yeah baby i'm back
bringing it the champ showing what he's made of
right there and then a big spread eight points the
lead had been cut to one have you ever watched nba
basketball let me tell you i'm a big nba fan if
you don't know everybody on my stream knows i rock
the knicks all day even now being from brooklyn
when you see a basketball game where there's a big
lead the run that the the team that's behind makes
they come back but they have to tie the score or
take the lead because the team that had the lead
to start with they will start a push and push you
backwards and that could be demoralizing and this
is what happened here he cut it to one and then
boom an eight-point spread it's like an 8-0 run
in basketball this could be rough
it's it climbs all the way back in
this means this next round to me it'll be the
decider this could be the knockout blow if rape
puts up another five when this happened in real
time murray's you called it it was the second
strike right that first one doesn't seem to slow
them down and it shouldn't right keep keep being
confident trusting yourself but the second strike
and this was the one that ray solved uh and found
the idea of rook d to b8 not rook a to b8 and the
idea is you then play a5 and the back rank is a
serious problem with the pin on the bishop and uh
demetrius did not solve that correctly ray did and
it might have been the difference in that in that
particular critical sixth round so all right well
round seven is going to be coming up here just had
to show that that second strike and i'm like you
said i i'm with you it's a momentum thing right
you you punch him in the mouth ray rises to the
occasion and punches right back and uh we'll see
what we'll see what demetrius is made of right
here in round seven don't forget ray won the
first two matches demetrius won the next three
now rey has won one it's a three three match
score but rey's wins have been decisive
two of them so it's got to be right now that
demetrius delivers he's got to i'm going to tell
you straight up if he doesn't deliver now this
match is over that's my opinion got to deliver
right now with a decent score maybe a plus three
or a plus four to feel like he's still in it
it's funny and you and i could probably talk
basketball day but i've been really into
you know basketball like that you know called
the sabermetrics the stats that kind of say
among all the best teams how do we know early
in a season who the best of the best are right
and one of the things they track is that margin of
victory because it kind of shows when the team is
right when the team is feeling it and everyone's
clicking how badly are they beating teams right
and you just said something that made
me think of that that when rey is right
he wins by a lot right and it's interesting
to see there right because when dmitry or or
put it put it the other way it shows who the
to the maybe the less consistent teams are
when demetrius isn't right it feels like he kind
of loses it right he goes on tilt a little bit and
that's been the difference is that ray when wright
is getting big big scores that's a big point
uh you demetrious can put up big numbers he can
put the numbers in the 50s like no problem you
see that he can do that but the one that he lost
big was a 41 that was huge by the way they both
just missed that they both just missed puzzle
number 30. right he gets a 52 and loses by eight
that's ray showing how much of a boss he is so
you get the combination of you don't get your
number or the other guy puts up a number you go
what am i supposed to do when he does yeah right
well we'll take a look at that uh 30th
puzzle everybody so don't go anywhere
we'll we'll make sure that we see what both of
them missed they both played queen takes d1 in
the final position and i can't wait to see what
murray says about that one so we'll come back
to it but all right right now what matters
is dimitri regardless ray's running fast
yep this is critical guys this is it ray's
running super fast plus five at the moment
ray better slow down as far as the demetrius
fans are concerned because otherwise this could
be problems as demetrius tries to close the gap
but it's still five points yep demetrius feels to
have lost a little bit of his uh his momentum and
and his feel for these positions he's taking on
average it looks like a second or two longer than
ray oh and he misses his first puzzle number 43.
sorry second muscle second puzzle yeah and it's
still okay the problem is there's 22 seconds left
he cannot afford to mess up now and let ray
messed up he did and ray can add to the number
he's up six at the moment with only one puzzle
gone he's up seven he could go he's now up eight
and reign he's like a runaway thoroughbred
right now just look at the number plus
eight this plus nine this is ray roxton
the world champion showing his stuff
he finishes at 55. we see gymnast9a demetrius
slaughterpools hasn't sat down since that round
fell and and uh right on cue he he comes right
back to the to the table there but wow that was a
i i'm with you maurice and you know anything
can happen because we still haven't seen ray
put up a stinker i mean he might be due right
even the best in the world have bad rounds
so so but demetrius fans better be praying that
that happens here right because now what a lead an
18-point lead i want to bring up the third puzzle
um sorry the 30th puzzle that each of them missed
because i just want to see what happened here
um wow look at this one marie so they both i
saw it in real time this one i know for sure they
both found the first few moves oh no no they both
found b5 and then they took d1 because they both
missed queen takes back backward moves backward
moves get you every time that is absolutely
wrong but you and robert hess two guys i do
commentary with him both make points with that a
lot what is that about the backward move it's just
the psychology or just the optics of the board
right you're just so much likely to miss those
totally the optics no question about it human
beings look at the world through our eyes forward
we don't have eyes in the back of our heads if we
did backward would be a way we would we would see
and navigate very easily somebody comes up to you
from behind you feel the ebg bees it's just the
way we are this way the world the mind is wired
and that gets transferred onto the chess board
and backward moves just just don't see them as
easily yep and now the score is huge look at that
30 to 12 you said he needs to have one bad round
danny sorry he needs to have two horrible rounds
to lose this ray needs to drop blood eight points
this is the title right here i think the master is
because uh because yeah ray is putting
on a show and like you said when you're
putting up a 52 spot in rounds but look at the
difference right when when demetrius put up a 60
right in round five ray got a 56 when ray did a
60 demetrius was four puzzles worse right so it's
just and again it's you know these two guys are
the best that's why they're here but it's been the
story of what has separated ray robson from others
is it's just the consistency when you hit those
high 40s 50 puzzles 50 50 level puzzles and ray
already had his bad round it's called round three
that was his background hollywood has look at
the score of round three there maurice they both
that must have been a super odd round where the
algo happened to throw them a ton of puzzles
they hadn't seen because that is for those
two guys a 39 and a 46 is is epically low
definitely but my my question to you how many
rounds did ray score under 50 only one one
round ask the same question of his opponent
four rounds where he scored in the 40s and
that is the difference in the match yeah no well
said it's the consistency there and now we see
uh jimmis does miss his first puzzle he's in
the lead but he any i like what he's doing here
even if he goes down in flames maurice look at
even missing that puzzle he is still blazing he
knows that he has no chance unless he's going
to be dropping mid 50s consistently and he's
got to risk getting some wrong in the process
agreed agreed that's exactly right and he's up
for okay he's pausing now while rey's he's
catching up and there it was another error and
can he afford to keep blitzing which he probably
has to do can he not afford to keep blitzing
yeah he's got 51 but here comes ray not going
away yeah then when you have two wrong you're
just going to hesitate it's just a blink of
a hesitation but you don't want to make that
third mistake with 42 seconds left you just don't
want to you you don't want it and yeah maybe ray
ray has a perfect score ray is looking to get
60. and the third mistake the end of the match
that was that is it that is it mathematically
he will not be able to catch ray no matter
what and rey is aiming for 60 again you ask what
happens when you punch a champion in the mouth wow
this is what you see look at him leaning in
he wants 60. we can't even see him anymore
because oh and he gets his first wrong that
was a wait what is what what the bleep i've
never seen this before and and that looks like
a weird puzzle well he's at 58 can he do it
at 60 look at him he wanted
the 16 just not messed up
one but that is it the the match is
mathematically over right rockstar
but it's over well we'll start we'll
start round nine right away here and uh
as it's a matter of formalities unless unless
jimmis resigns the match i'm not exactly sure
how that works we i don't know that we plan
for it to be over in eight rounds so we're i'm
i'm gonna let the team decide but if we're
continuing we'll start right away here we go
yeah we're gonna play it all out
for the fans right for the fans
um but you're right maurice it's mathematically
over no matter what happens here in the final
two rounds ray robson defends his title as
puzzle battle world champion and i'm gonna say
well the way he's doing i probably
should shut my mouth but it's possible
very possible that ray scores his first his second
score under 50. it's possible yeah yeah and he
i won't say this because you you kind of hinted
at it i i think with your tone there and i
marie ray has been just one of the classiest guys
we've seen in any any puzzle event we've done
i mean you'll notice even in the end of the
match with ikaro right he wasn't putting on
the heat in fact you can claim a win instead
of continuing to to beat your opponent you can
actually just press a claim win button
the moment they get their third strike
and he said he did that several times
today against his opponent so he is uh
ray is a very classy guy he's not interested in
rubbing salt in anyone's wounds so i wouldn't
be surprised if you're right if he kind of kind of
slows down the gas here in the final couple rounds
uh we're saying that and yet
he's at 28 with no mistake so far
it's true maybe yeah maybe not gonna be in flow
he knows that this is the only person in the world
who challenges him at this right so
maybe he wants to say to him not again
yeah i was going to say not again i'm going to
i'm going to have you remember this beat down
so next year you're thinking the same
thing because you know demetrius have
been dreaming about this for a whole year this
rematch and what happened the same thing again
yeah i was going to say that's the other angle is
no no i'm i'm going to rub it in because i want
him to remember how this feels but we'll know the
moment of truth if demetrius gets a third strike
and ray claims a win then uh then then we'll see
but um right now as we applauded last round even
if he gets a third strike i agree with demetrius
strategy of just going as fast as he can because
it's kind of what you have to do but at this point
it's um okay so the third strike has occurred
we'll see if ray claims the winner continues
so ray is going ray now hits 42 with no errors
whatsoever with a ton of time on his clock will
ray claim the win or will we try to get that 60
spot again i mean no he'll never make 60. not
with this amount of time left we see he's still
still going here and here it's just in fact it's
it's it might be likely that he'll only stay in
the 40s again like i said just because he doesn't
feel the same pressure on himself anymore he does
have enough time to break into 50 something if
he solves the next two puzzles pretty quickly but
he's not at that same frenetic wild pace yeah it
looks like he will make it to 50 but again just
barely because the feeling isn't the same
anymore you know you've won you don't
need to rack up the numbers and there he is at 51.
wow wow wow there were a couple puzzles there 51
51 is his second lowest score shame on him shame
on him wow pick up your game man that shows how
bad at 39 was but man this is sick this is there
there were a couple too that he saw there that
i was just shaking my head i was like what i
mean the way he was it i don't remember which
one it was but we're going to start the next
round because at this point out of respect for
demetrius a lot of poulos we won't delay the event
any further though we will have an interview with
our uh champion so don't go anywhere we'll
catch up with ray robson and talk to him about
all things puzzles i i want maurice to ask him
some questions about about his love for puzzles
because uh it's something that they they share
and uh maybe ray should tune into your channel
from time to time yeah yeah and just saw all my
puzzles and ruin it for everybody who's following
i mean the guy's a beast certainly would
love to have him on the show at some point
uh we'll we'll see about that uh but just simply
extraordinary the speed of which he solves
yeah and uh you know out of the gates
it's one of the things that's funny
it in the early most the time today mary's
correct if i'm wrong but it it feels like up
to the 25 marker and even the 30 marker gymnast
is actually the faster with his mouse right
he's actually the faster player he tended to be
reaching 27-28 before ray did a lot of the time
um but it's when the puzzles hit the the the
40s and 50s that where the consistency kicks in
and and the speed is slightly less
important yeah interesting observation
you've got to solve those puzzles
i mean when you get to 60 puzzles
that means you're solving the puzzles all
solving everything in five seconds a puzzle
right you're averaging five seconds five
seconds to look at a tough chest position
and without a blank like bing bing bing bing
and just go for it just really ridiculous speed
you give a difficult puzzle a difficult chess
position to a player and you solve it in five
seconds the whole thing not just solve it and
that's assuming they get them all right right if
they miss one then you know yeah that's amazing
you're right though how did they get to 68 like
what is what well like what in the world right it
has to be one of those perfect runs where you know
the algorithm randomly delivers them a whole so at
that point it's purely mouse speed right and they
they probably didn't miss any and they probably
had a lot of puzzles they had seen before and it
worked out speaking of not missing any raise at
52 no mistakes and 52 seconds left on his clock
will we see an absurd number put get put up 60
looks well within reach wow is he going to score
one of his best scores ever what a statement
round it would be and look at him still rocking
these puzzles at 56. 58 he's perfect at 58. he's
got 60. he's gonna oh no as soon as i said it
he's made a mistake but he's got 59 he's going
to get 60 looks like yeah and there it is he's
going to score his best score of the whole day
but look and look at gymnasts we're going to
have 260s here as long as jimmys can deliver
on his final puzzle that's right look at that
he's not into the 60s in the last round 62
by ray it looks like he'll end up around 64.
poetic number for chess no he didn't well yes
he does yes he did yes he did and you called it
and he closed out best number incredible both of
them showing what stars i mean they and jimmis
sorry demetrious a lot of poulos i keep saying
jimmy's because his name uh his username but shout
out to him because he goes down but not without a
fight putting up his best score of the entire day
in the last round even knowing that it was a moot
point at that at that point so wow maurice this
has been wild these guys have uh have entertained
us and i can't wait to to hear what ray has to
say so don't go anywhere when we return we will
have our final thoughts on the day and interview
with the back-to-back puzzle battle world
chess champion if you're out there kids
and uh and you want to be like ray robson
someone's got to beat this man in the next
few years so somebody start solving
some puzzles to take this guy out
maurice and i will be back with an
interview and final thoughts in just a
moment
and we are back with our now back-to-back puzzle
battle world chess champion ray how does it feel
knowing that you took home this time 8k and
you had to win it all to get to get any money
yeah uh it feels really good um yeah i don't
know i think i felt a lot of pressure um
coming into this event and obviously i didn't
really know what the what the bracket was going
to be who was going to be playing until just
the other day um so then i saw obviously jimmy's
was really my main competition and it seemed
like we're destined to meet in the finals so
i was waiting for this match for for a little
while now and yeah i was was pretty nervous
um i think we both were and yeah i think it
was tough for both of us to play in this fight
ray you played last year he played the same
opponent last year you know he must have been
working his tail off the whole year for this
moment alone you do other things obviously as
a top player what's it like to know that there's
one thing in this person's mind and that's to beat
you i i don't know if i would describe it that
way i'm i'm pretty sure he does other things um
he does play chess himself over the board he
probably has played more over the board than
me in the past year um and i'm i'm not sure that
he's actually spent more time than me i'm not sure
that anyone spent more time with me in practicing
puzzle rush so i think that's actually my biggest
advantage over over everyone is i've just um i've
just done it more often than anyone else i think
well again talk about that i mean we i feel like
i want to ask you similar questions that i did
last year and tell similar stories where when
your coach alex ownership when you were 16
told me i needed to add more 3000 plus
puzzles because ray was solving all of
was memorizing them and i didn't believe him right
and then and then when puzzle rush launched and
you sort of took the world by storm with this
secret spicy caterpillar username and then i
made you reveal who you were because we had to
make sure people knew that it was a real thing so
i mean how many puzzles would you say you've
solved at this point and when you reach that
mid-40s mark up to the the mid 50s how many of
those have you seen before on average so i mean
i i can't calculate how many i've solved that's
probably i mean someone someone else would do that
better than me um i mean you can see people's
attempts how many attempts they've done in
puzzle rush so i assume i have you know probably
the most um but a lot of those are me trying
to get like high scores so i'm i'm going really
fast in the beginning and if i strike out early
i just end so they're not really full attempts
but um for for the 40 50 the harder puzzles
it depends like probably in the past i
think most of the top guys would have
known almost all of them but you guys are always
adding puzzles so um there's there's definitely
um puzzles that are in the more difficult range
that we don't know and um also recently i think
you guys had a lot of like tricky puzzles that are
actually much earlier on and that is why i think
some of our scores weren't as consistent as maybe
it seemed like they were going to be going in
do you have a secret beyond practice i mean is
it is it just practice is is is it do you study
the other puzzle like puzzle books or go over
studies by by great play great people like trotsky
and rink and all those guys that you translate
that into this skill set or is it just about
raw solving of these puzzles well you need to have
some sort of background in puzzle solving tactical
ability so obviously all the work i did as a
regular chess player or one of my main strengths
was tactics and calculation that obviously helped
a lot and that still helps um in the early puzzles
but i mean of course it helps in the
harder more difficult puzzles as well
but um yeah and this type of format it's
really like to be able to solve those
puzzles as quickly as as let's say jimis
and i we're solving um some of those rounds
there's there's no way anyone can humanly do that
unless they've just seen the puzzle enough times
and i mean people have different methods of going
about trying to learn the puzzles some people
like directly just search um for maybe specific
rating range and they try to just memorize puzzles
um i don't think jimison i do that uh i mean i'm
not sure about jimmy's but i don't think he does
the way i do it is i just play a lot and so i just
see a lot of puzzles and then if i get them wrong
i just review them so i'm not like trying to
memorize every single problem in the database but
just by playing so much i'm encountering
most of the most difficult puzzles
it's it's wild it's mind-blowing it's honestly
amazing and it has even you know super strong
players and grand masters just in awe of what
you guys can do um i i don't even know that i
i have many other questions besides just
again a huge congratulations to you man
and how how many more years do you think you
can stay at the top i know i know you're uh
you're a super humble guy and i'm not asking
you for a bold statement but at this point
two-part question do you think the difference
between you and jim is when you get to that
hi to that mid 40s low 50s actually is chest
strength because maurice and i talked a lot
about this and said like hey what makes
rey special is he's a puzzle specialist
right like demetrius but you're also a very
strong grandmaster and it does seem that
where the rubber meets the road there in the
tougher puzzles is where you're able to separate
and be a little more consistent so do you think
it's chest strength that maybe separates you and
gimmicks like general chest strength and two
how long do you think you could be at the top
um i mean chess strength it helps somewhat but i
mean like bashir or hikaru are stronger players
than me and they don't if they played against
gymnasts it's most likely they'll lose right um so
it's not just about chest strength um and i don't
know i actually think that the harder puzzles
often favor the like give less of an advantage
to the so-called stronger player just because
those are the ones that people have
probably seen a lot and might have
remembered um and like so if if we both remember
the same and i think james is not slower than me
and mouse speed um it's not really confirming
much of an advantage so i'm not really sure
what the difference was today um i felt
like he did miss more puzzles than i
was expecting in the in those later ones
and i'm not really sure perhaps he hadn't
practiced as much as me recently or maybe he was
just nervous i'm not sure what happened exactly
um because usually um he is doing better in this
and as far as the trying to retain the title
um yeah i don't know i to be honest i'm
probably not gonna play as much puzzle rush
next year i probably i'm gonna like try to become
2700 fee day that's my my main goal right now um
so i don't know like if other people if they keep
it up um i have no clue perhaps i could i mean i
could definitely lose um next year even um so it's
really hard to say the one thing i will say is um
i hope that in future years um you have some sort
of format which is more like the like the first
year like last year where it's a little bit more
open so that people can try to qualify because i
know a lot of strong strong puzzle specialists
who would have loved a chance to play but
this one was kind of invitation only it's
fair yeah and uh just because you asked
we're going to do it next year there's an
open qualifier you heard it it'll be done
maurice any final thoughts before i give a
huge shout out that everyone needs to go join
you at your channel well congratulations ray in a
topic that i am going to talk about on my channel
uh in a moment is about the difference between
solving puzzles and playing chess at the elite
level i mean you made this point you don't want
to keep doing this you want to be a 2700 player
what's the difference why is it that you
could be such a dominant puzzle solver
but not be the best players in the world um
well first of all puzzle solving is a specific
ability you know that there's one solution there's
supposed to be one solution sometimes you guys
have multiple solutions or or your solution is
actually not a solution but in general there's
there's one solution oh there was the rook and [
__ ] i remember the brook and bishop versus rook
from today about that that one was uh that was
a bad puzzle i called myself out on it just so
you know and we're gonna remove that one but that
was a super unfair puzzle and hikaru got lucky and
got it right you played a move that should have
been winning but but it wasn't right um but yeah
so there's only one solution so and it's usually
tactical um so you kind of know what to look for
if you're familiar with a lot of the the patterns
that are common in just tactics and in studies
in particular then you already have an advantage
and obviously with something like puzzle rush it's
very specific where you kind of have uh you're
kind of seeing a lot of the same patterns over
and over so over time you just adapt to those um
but by the way maurice i really i've seen your
stream i really like your your stream is very
good so everyone should check out more recent
stream um and i think for like let's say if
there were five minute puzzle rush battles
i think that's where i would have more of an
advantage in the harder puzzles compared to
someone um lower rated but also you know people
like kikaro's other really strong players would
also have more of an advantage there so two
requests the reigning world champion wants an
open qualification format and you want five-minute
puzzle battles i can definitely deliver on the
first one we'll see about the second but anyway
right no uh jokes aside it's awesome again this is
this is super super entertaining and educational
for for the the viewers can't wait till next year
so uh so thanks thanks and again congratulations
congratulations thank you my co-host
grand master maurice ashley i'm gonna i'm gonna
sign off and again congratulate the world champion
and uh thank you both make sure everyone sticks
around we're about to raid grand master mauricio
maurice ashley's channel which
is why we're letting him go and
ray congratulations again to you all right
thanks so much guys bye guys all right guys
all right well there you have it fans and
we still more than 9000 of you that stuck
around for that interview on just twitch
alone and so we hope that you stick around
and uh join us with the raid party following
grand master maurice ashley at his channel
the bracket is before your very eyes this is
what happened today everyone grandmaster ray
robson defends his title is once again
the puzzle battle world chess champion
and uh but it was it was close like like he said
he felt that him and jimmys were both nervous
today him and demetrius a lot of poulos um and
maybe they weren't at their absolute best overall
but either way their last round they did to give
us a show 64 and 61 respectively it was crazy so
anyway congratulations to ray again who shows
that uh shows that he has still demanded beat
this was our final bracket score in front
of you here we've got uh what was overall
as maurice and i drew the conclusion it was just
a little more consistency from ray and you also
saw when he won he won bigger right the round
the demetrius put up a 60 there in round five
ray kept pace right but when ray put up 60
uh it was it was a wider margin of victory
right and that ultimately is why he he walked
away with a 48 to 12 score even though it felt
much much closer than that so well again thank you
to everyone this has been an awesome week if you
didn't get the memo here's your last reminder
it's free puzzle battles for everyone today on
chess.com as a celebration of all of chess.com's
puzzle features come to an end we've had puzzle
rush three minute puzzle rush survival puzzle
rush five minute multiple puzzle battle events
and it all came down to this championship where
ray robson took the title home so uh go check out
and try out puzzle battles on chess.com it is free
if you haven't yet for the whole crew here working
super hard our events team all of our mods and
staff that make this possible thank you so much
for all the hard work you've done not just today
but this entire week for my awesome co-host who
we are rating grandmaster maurice ashley go to
his channel and hit that follow button you won't
regret it seriously it's one of the most needs to
be talked about more things happening on twitch
right now because maurice's streams are super
educational and awesome so for the crew for the
team for everybody like i said thanks for being
here and we will see you next week on chess.com tv
so